Hello everybody!
Hello!
Hi, I'm Lukey's cat.
You can tell when I swapped the Chinese accent with my hello.
Hello!
You're getting in the mood already?
Yeah, I'm getting in the mood.
It's been a while since I spoke.
Well, that's not true.
Really?
How long?
Well, I speak Chinese to my parents, but like...
Oh really?
Then you're like an expert, aren't you?
No, I am not.
I think you're better than me.
No, no, no.
You actually know how to read and write.
That's different.
What do you mean?
No, but you speak to your parents in Chinese.
I speak to my parents in English.
Bro, I like... okay.
No, no, no, no.
Cause like, I speak like... like... like elementary school Chinese though.
Really?
No, I doubt it.
No.
Yeah, cause they're like, what do you wanna eat?
And I'll be like, I wanna eat this.
I think you're... no.
I think you're gonna teach me some words today.
I don't know.
I'm scared now.
I was... yeah, I was like, okay.
Let me think what I can... hmm... slang words.
Hmm...
Yeah, I know... curse words.
What?
Chinese curse words?
I mean, isn't that like the first thing everybody learns?
That's true.
In every language, you learn like the curse words for every language.
Yeah?
That is so true.
Of course, you wanna curse out your teammates a little.
Yeah, that's true.
By the way, guys.
Hiro and I were like, talking before... we were like in the... in the starting stream.
She has... she streamed 16 hours yesterday because of Apex and Honkai.
I was like...
Yeah, I... I was... I was going crazy last night.
It was really... it was crazy.
Because I really did not expect like the Honkai story to be like that long, the update.
So I was like, okay, I stream Apex.
You know what?
It's updated.
I'm gonna play it for a little while and then pick him night.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, so like... I've asked Ditter this, but how much money have you spent on Honkai?
Uh... wait.
Yeah?
I don't know.
Do you have... how many characters do you have?
How many characters do you have on Honkai?
Let me see.
I think I can open my game right now.
Wait.
Let me... let me check.
Because Ditto has 37.
Now, apparently that's the total, right?
Is that the total amount of characters Honkai has?
She has 37?
That's kind of... that's a lot.
But I have more.
I have...
Wait, you have more?
There's more than 37?
There's 40 and total...
There's 48 in total!
Yeah, I... I... I like... I played since the beginning, but I also took a break for like 6 months and I came back 2 months ago, I think.
Oh, okay.
So like...
So then you have to catch up after... after taking a break.
And then you got...
So you... the only characters you're missing are the ones that you didn't get when you were at break, right?
Yeah!
Because I was collecting all of them and then after that I was like, oh crap.
I have like so much like... so many other games to play.
So I was like, okay, I gotta take a break from that.
And like 6 months later I came back and I'm like, oh, I really wanna play it.
Really wanna play it.
Oh my god.
Wait, what other gacha games do you play other than Honkai?
Now?
Yeah.
Well...
Actually none other... because it's expensive, okay?
Yeah, it's true.
It's gacha.
Yeah, you only... like if you play more than like... I think 2 is like the maximum anybody should have because like 1 is like crazy.
If you spend like a little bit on it, like it's enough for like a month or 2 months, you know what I mean?
Yeah.
It's... it's crazy.
So I only play...
Honkai now, but I play Genshin too before.
Wait, wait, wait.
How many characters do you have in Genshin then?
Don't ask.
I had like 3 accounts, dude.
I had like 3 accounts.
So...
They're both like... they're all from like the same company too, right?
Mi... Mihoyo?
Yeah, it's Mihoyo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh.
They're... they have like... they have like the algorithm or like the...
The structure of it's set.
Yeah, I played... I played Honkai... like Honkai Impact 3rd.
That one.
Yeah.
Yeah, I played that one too.
That's why.
Oh wait, are you talking about Honkai Star Real?
Yeah.
Yeah, the one before that is like part of Honkai series.
Wait, what's the difference between Honkai Impact and Honkai Star Real?
Honkai Impact is waifu only basically.
Waifu only, yeah.
Yeah, it's basically waifu only.
Okay.
Oh, so Star Real has... has meh.
Yeah.
It's probably like the same universe though.
I see.
It's so...
But it's fun.
But I know... and like I heard like Star Real is sort of like similar to like Genshin, like the open world, right?
It... it... it's similar but like not similar at the same time.
It's like actually really not similar.
I think Genshin is... is...
Sorry to say, it's a little bit tiring because like you have to do everything manually.
Yeah.
But like in... in Star Real you can kind of like leave your phone there or leave it going and like you'll be...
Oh, so you can like...
Yeah, you can relax while... while looking at it.
I see.
You see, I... I don't know anything about like gacha games in general.
Because like for me, I'm also scared of getting addicted.
It is... it is addictive.
It is...
it is addictive.
Honestly, it is really addictive.
I try not to play any gacha game because like I'm scared of getting addicted and I'm scared when I get addicted that I'm gonna spend money.
Yeah.
Because...
I think that's the problem everybody has with like gacha games.
Like damn, that... that woman is so hot that...
Like I must have...
You know, it's like wow.
Yeah, because I already spend money on Fortnite skins and like it... it's... it's a problem.
Yeah.
I'm only...
Fortnite skins?
Yes, Fortnite skins.
Dang, because it's funny.
Like Peter Griffin... like I have Peter Griffin, John Cena, Dragon Ball Z.
What?
I have the like emo dance on it.
I have Ganon style.
Fortnite.
Really?
Because it's funny.
I haven't touched Fortnite like once ever and I was like...
To be fair, I don't... I don't like buy the skins to play with it.
I buy the skins like just because I think it's funny.
Like I don't even play Fortnite.
You don't play?
You don't play Fortnite skins?
I only play... I only play on stream.
I only play...
Wait.
But it's funny.
You do...
It's like how you see like...
You see the pretty characters and you're like, oh, they're so pretty.
True.
You know what?
I can't judge you.
I see the funny Fortnite skin.
I'm like, oh, it's so funny.
Well, yeah.
I get it.
You know what?
I can't judge you because...
Yeah.
Financial choices, you know?
Because you don't play gacha games so you can...
You can like buy all the skins you want.
Yeah, exactly.
I save my money by not playing gacha games.
And instead, I spend that money I save from gacha games to play Fortnite...
To buy Fortnite skins.
I...
To buy Fortnite skins?
I don't know which is the lesser evil.
Honestly.
Okay.
Yeah.
I can't...
Yeah, we don't know what's the lesser evil, but we both spend money irresponsibly.
It's true.
But you know what?
Waifu for life, right?
I haven't heard that in like years, honestly.
Until like in 10 years, the game gets shut down for Genshin Impact.
No!
For the sequel of Genshin Impact.
Dude, that's so sad.
Servers eventually...
I'm like, I'm like...
Eventually, your waifus... your waifus will disappear, you know?
Because the servers will get shut down.
That's what happens to like so many games.
That's why it's so scary.
That's why I don't do gacha too, because of the server.
I feel like servers tend to get shut down too for gacha games eventually.
And then all those waifus, all those digital waifus will be gone.
Because they're not real.
But the mihoyo is pretty good at keeping like...
That's true.
Mihoyo is...
I don't see like an end to it, you know?
You know what I mean?
Yeah, I feel like mihoyo is sort of like...
It's sort of like Riot, where it's like League-led legends will never die.
So I feel like...
Oh my god, Liga.
Yeah, League of Legends actually...
Never die.
I tried to learn how to play League.
I never learned how to play League.
So I was like learning how to play it.
And it's crazy.
It's like too many heroes in it.
And I'm like, dude, what does this guy do?
What are the combos?
I don't know.
I'm saying there's like a hundred heroes.
Yeah.
It's really difficult actually.
Honestly.
That's why I was like...
That's why I could never learn League.
And also because like it's so fucking toxic too.
So...
Yeah!
It's really toxic.
I heard like...
Like people...
Yeah, yeah, what were you gonna say?
No, you can go ahead.
No, okay.
I've seen toxicity.
I heard from my friends that the moderating team for League is so intense now.
That if you say anything toxic, they'll like ban you instantly.
So people got like super creative on how to be toxic to each other.
Wait, really?
Yeah, yeah.
They'll be like super passive aggressive.
Like you did a good job when they clearly didn't do a good job.
So just to get away from the...
Yeah, the sarcasm just comes in.
Yeah.
Just to get away from the filters and the bans.
They'll just be like...
It'll be like super passive aggressive.
Oh, yeah.
So it's like good job, smile.
It's just another level.
Oh, wait.
Is this what you meant when your mic was gonna cut off?
I see your mouth moving.
Oh, okay.
Guys.
Hiro's mic is...
Hiro's mic started cutting off.
Now she's just mute now.
Is this Chinese?
Sorry, I got carried away with speaking English.
Oh.
Whoa, are you okay?
You're back.
Welcome back.
Wait, never mind.
Okay, welcome back.
Never mind.
See my problem?
It's crazy.
This thing is like crazy.
Okay, I gotta...
Whoa, she's gotta...
We'll never know.
She might have to be a PNG, guys.
Like her...
Apparently her PC fucking exploded.
I was like, what?
So like, goodbye.
She's gone.
It's like I could hear her voice suddenly.
This guy is always...
She's gonna be a PNG, guys.
Her PC is fighting with her.
See, I'm not the only one with PC issues.
Okay?
Guys, all VTubers have similar problems.
I'm not...
I'm not the only one.
Am I back?
Oh, you're back.
You're back.
Yeah.
Oh, God.
Yeah, that's scary.
It's so scary.
You just suddenly stopped talking.
I was like...
You know, like, it's only when I screen share.
It's so annoying.
That's so weird.
Yeah.
Like, Discord should screen share.
Like, anything else.
Like, it's all fine.
Like, everything is all fine.
Yeah.
Except screen share.
It's so annoying.
That's so weird.
Like, all my USB, you know, my keyboard, my mouse, my...
Like, everything else just...
My mic.
Yeah.
Just stops working, right?
You sent me a PNG.
Yeah.
That I can put on the screen.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right, guys.
Sorry.
She...
We're just waiting until the PNG comes back.
What were you going to say about League, Yido?
League?
Yeah.
Well, League, I actually am going...
I think there's like competitions.
Like, I think there's a big competition soon or something.
I'm going to be like doing a watch along for League or something.
Oh, yeah.
On PDPD and League.
Is it like an eSport or...
Yeah.
It is the eSport tournament.
I'm not sure which one it is.
Because I don't follow League too much.
Apparently, it's like MSI.
I think so.
I'm not sure.
But like, because of that too, I'm like, oh crap.
I really got to learn like...
You got to like know what's going on.
I kind of know what's going on.
It's just really difficult to like, you know...
Actually, Chinese is like not my mother language as well.
You know, right?
Yeah.
Wait, wait.
English, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
How did you...
How did you get so good at Chinese?
I have to...
Actually, I used to stream like everyday in English and then like I converted...
As soon as I went on PDPD, I like just stream in Chinese everyday just to practice.
Just to practice, yeah.
Yeah.
I had...
I was like so scared because I can't read chat, you know?
I could only read chat in like English before.
Yeah.
So I was really like, oh crap.
I can't understand anything at all.
So I was like, okay.
I gotta learn Chinese just to read chat.
Oh my god.
You're like...
You're like so...
You have like the brain capacity for like language learning because you know like Japanese too, right?
Yeah.
You can speak Japanese sort of fluently.
I...
That's also like...
I learned it since like young as well.
Oh my god.
I used to learn like a lot like Japanese and Chinese.
That's insane.
Oh my gosh.
That's like...
Like...
Like language learning is like one of the hardest skills to have because like you actually need...
Like it's a part of your sector in your brain.
Like section in your brain for...
Like you speak it too, right?
Every day?
Okay.
That...
Good...
A good...
Good question.
Wait, don't shoot.
Don't shoot.
That's a good question.
Hold that.
Yeah.
I kind of want to...
I want to hear you speak Chinese actually.
I was kind of excited.
You want to hear me...
Oh, speak Chinese?
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
Wait.
Okay.
I feel like...
Oh my god.
It's been so long since I spoke like Mandarin as well.
Yeah.
I'm like...
Wow.
I've spoken Mandarin before to you like a long time ago.
Have you?
Yeah.
Wait.
I don't even remember that.
That's how long it was.
That was very...
I think it was really long ago.
I like how like you're not on the screen so it looks like I'm just talking to myself.
Like I'm talking to the voices in my head.
Yeah.
I'm like trying to find like...
The voices in my head.
No, no, no.
I'm a ghost actually.
Oh my god.
You know what it's like to ghost in Chinese?
She's haunting me.
Why?
Yeah.
Play.
Go ahead.
Your Chinese is great.
What do you mean?
I said one word.
One word.
Oh my god.
You're a natural.
Wow.
Yeah.
Your Chinese is way...
Better than me.
Of course.
That's not true.
I can't even read or write.
I stopped learning Chinese.
Like I stopped like having like teachers for Chinese since like third grade.
Wow.
Yeah.
Because I'm like...
Okay, that's a long time ago.
Exactly!
Because my parents were like...
I think like... oh yeah, because like...
I moved out of Canada.
And I moved to Asia.
And then like, we had a choice... I had a choice between like... oh, like learn Chinese or learn French.
And then my parents were like, you're Canadian.
You should learn French.
And we'll talk to you in Chinese.
So you can get double... Did you learn French too?
Yeah, yeah.
I learned French until like, I graduated high school.
So like, they're like, you have to learn... you should learn French.
We will talk to you in Chinese.
So that's gonna be how you're learning it.
I was like, okay.
So I never learned how to...
I never learned... like the only thing I know how to read and like write are like, you know, like the basics for like Chinese.
Like like cat, dog, like...
Mom, Dad...
Like, I know how to write... horse...
Like your spoken Chinese is like way better, isn't it?
Well, like it's cause like... okay, you know how like... okay, cause like I lived in...
I lived in like China as well.
So like, I don't know, like you know uh, like the shows there.
So I would just like watch random shows that would pop up on TV.
And then like I had nothing to do.
So like I would I would just like watch the shows.
So like, you know when you listen to a lot of shows, then you can sort of like understand.
Actually, yeah, that's a lot of like how I learn and stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
I like to watch stuff, watch videos.
So like, you know, there's nothing else playing on TV.
So I just like, like I'll just really be watching random TV shows and then I just slowly build up like speaking wise.
But then I still have like... like um...
I had like... I don't... I never really liked speaking Chinese.
Like um... in high school.
Oh, Cantonese!
Yeah, I could speak like Mandarin and Cantonese.
Like more so Cantonese because I speak Cantonese at home.
But like I... like at high school I didn't like speaking Cantonese like out loud because like my friends would make fun of me.
Because I have an English accent.
Because like you know in Chinese there's different tones.
And it's like very strict.
Like the tonation.
It's very... yeah.
It's extremely strict.
Yeah, yeah.
So like...
I didn't care about that.
So you know I'd be like speaking...
like if I had a question I'll speak in the English tone for questions.
And stuff.
So I don't like follow the... I don't follow the um... Yeah.
I actually have that problem a lot too.
Like I try and fix it as much as I can.
But like...
Because we speak in English so often.
So it's like... yeah.
This fluctuation isn't it?
Yeah.
Yeah that's like a problem for me too.
Even though like...
Yeah and then like my chat will make fun of me.
Yeah.
So like that's why I was like...
So then like I wouldn't speak...
I rarely speak um...
like Chinese in public.
Like with my friends.
Because like they would just keep making fun of me.
They're like say it again!
Say it again!
And I'll be like... No.
I'll be like... No!
You just cannot make fun of me!
But it's actually really cute!
Wait you...
You heard me say one word.
What do you mean?
Yeah!
Okay okay.
Okay well let's try to have a conversation.
You start.
You go first.
Okay.
And then see if I can understand it.
I think you can.
Like what am I gonna talk about?
Oh.
Wait.
Ni hao.
Yeah.
Today's weather is really nice.
Isn't it?
Did she just ask you how the weather's really nice?
Oh.
Yeah.
Classic conversation.
Wow.
Today's weather is really nice.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Usually you only speak in English right?
Usually.
Yeah.
Well like to my parents I speak in Cantonese.
Cantonese.
I want to hear you speak Cantonese.
I'm so...
Wait.
Do you understand Cantonese?
So okay.
So I actually did not understand Cantonese for a long time.
Then I learned a little bit from like videos and also being on Vidi Vidi.
And also I stay... Do you know where I live right now?
I'm like not... Wait.
Where do you live?
Okay.
So I'm actually I'm like Japanese but I stay in Malaysia.
Oh.
Wait.
That's so interesting.
Do you know Malaysian then?
The local language?
Yeah.
A little bit.
Oh.
That's so interesting.
Wait.
So you're like super multilingual then.
Yeah.
I can kind of speak like...
How do I say?
Like people here mix your like languages really often.
Yeah.
So they'll mix English with Canto and stuff like that.
So that's why I hear like a lot of things every day.
So I'm like okay.
I can kind of understand what everybody is saying.
That's similar to me because I learned Cantonese first.
And then but like my extended family mostly speaks like on my dad's side mostly speaks like Mandarin.
And then like when I was like growing up I stayed with my grandpa for a bit as well.
And my grandpa only speaks like Mandarin but he could like understand Cantonese and stuff.
So then he'll like talk to me in Mandarin.
That's how I like learned like Mandarin.
Because like people just like talk to me in that in Mandarin instead of Cantonese.
And then your spoken is so good and when you try and like read and write it's like crap.
Oh yeah.
Like I can't read or write so...
Before I would like... I remember when I first did like a I try to speak Chinese stream.
And then people were like typing to me in Chinese.
Really?
You did?
I tried to speak Chinese stream.
Yeah, yeah.
I did like for like a solo.
And then people were like typing to me in Chinese.
I was like I'm sorry I cannot read this.
Like you guys have to type to me in English.
You wanna try again today?
Well you can read it.
You can read it for me.
Yeah.
I can barely read English let alone...
Like I can barely read English let alone Chinese.
I can.
Is that all you can say?
What are you talking about?
I can't.
We're gonna be like little kids today.
Yeah honestly I can read actually okay.
拿豆皮本中文 And then I can't read after that.
Someone in my chat was like 拿豆皮本中文 And then I don't know what else.
My traditional Chinese is crap.
Oh yeah, yeah.
I know like traditional and simplified.
Yeah, yeah.
I think in Malaysia they use simplified as well.
So my traditional is really bad.
Like I'm trying to read it and I'm like crap.
It's easier to learn traditional.
I mean traditional is like really difficult.
Cause like that's why I simplify.
Yeah!
But like when you know traditional you can tell what is the simplified version because you know you're like wait that sort of looks like the traditional version.
And I learned traditional in Canada.
I learned traditional.
So like and then I remember like I remember oh wait no I did like when I like moved overseas I remember like I had one I think like I had like one lesson in like simplified and then I was like I was writing like write the sentence.
So then I wrote it in like traditional and they were like what is this?
And I was like I was like this is me.
This is traditional.
This is me.
But traditional is very it's like much harder that's why I like to simplify.
Cause there's more strokes in it.
You know how I learned like when I went to Bilibidi at first I learned using Duolingo as well.
So I was like ah.
Wait is it like Duolingo is not like a good like learning like not like a good like main learning tool type deal.
I was like very confused on where to learn.
I was like okay you know what I'm gonna open Duolingo and learn it there.
I think like Chinese is like one of the hardest languages to learn because of how many intonations and like characters there are for like writing and reading as well.
I feel like.
Yeah.
I just cause like I just I don't know like Cantonese has like more intonation like more tones than like Mandarin.
I don't remember it was like 8 or something.
Oh yeah.
There's like a lot of Chinese dialects I think.
Like I don't know how many there are.
Do you know the Chinese tongue twister?
Which one?
The one with like one character like one uh what was it one like it sounds like the same but it means different things.
God what one was that one?
Oh the Shi Shi Shi.
Eww that one I I hate it like I don't know but like when I first learned Chinese I think like people love to hear like new beginners making mistakes or something and and they forced me to read all those tongue twisters and like I was going crazy.
I was like.
What?
Shi Shi Shi Shi Shi Shi?
I'm like no I can't read this.
No!
Try it.
Try one.
Try one of them.
What?
Let me see.
Is there any like easy tongue twister?
If it's a tongue twister it's not meant to be easy.
There's one about milk as well.
A milk?
What's the milk one called?
Like Nai Nai something like that.
Nai Nai.
I don't remember.
Like there's a lot of tongue twisters.
It's too difficult I think.
Maybe you can try.
You know what?
I can't even read.
What do you mean?
How do I do tongue twisters if I can't even read?
I can't even read.
It's so difficult honestly.
Tongue twisters I think in any language is difficult.
That's true.
English ones are pretty difficult.
There's some really difficult ones as well.
I think like the Chinese ones are more so like the whole fact that it sounds the same.
It all sounds very similar.
But it's all different meaning.
You gotta know what the tone is and all that.
It's like basically it's testing your tonation reading type deal.
There's so much.
Stop avoiding the Chinese tongue twister.
Yeah Hiro.
Stop avoiding it.
I've gone through like torture doing those tongue twisters.
Like every single time I do a collab with like...
Oh Hiro, we'll teach you Chinese today.
And then they always give me a tongue twister.
I can't take it.
And I'm like Hiro teach me Chinese.
I was like Hiro teach me Chinese.
Anyway do a tongue twister too.
Yeah.
Well okay.
So wait.
Actually teach you something today.
Like useful things.
Like you want to learn like slang or something?
Yeah yeah yeah.
Teach me some modern slang.
But you might know the slang if you talk to your parents right?
Oh no I don't.
Like I don't progress.
What?
I don't progress.
I'm like stuck in this time chamber of the Chinese I've known.
Honestly.
Like I never learn anything new.
Just asking.
Do you want to learn curse words or do you know all the curse words already?
I feel like I know a lot of the curse words already because like you know like when your parents are driving the car and they start yelling start yelling at the drivers in the car.
What?
Wow.
What did they yell?
I'm so interested.
I don't know.
My mom watches my stream.
Wait really?
But I learn...
Wait wait.
Your mom watches your stream?
Oh okay.
But it's okay right?
Like you learn it from your parents.
Yeah that's true.
That's true.
Yeah.
You can tell me one I'll tell you one.
I think the easiest one is like I think everybody knows is like the Chao Ni Ma.
Chao Ni Ma.
Oh no.
Yeah.
It's like and then I know okay this one I've heard of that one.
Yes I've heard of that one.
What?
Well the most tame one is the most tame one is Ba Po which is like bitch.
So...
Well yeah that's pretty tame.
Yeah it's pretty tame.
There's a lot of things I could say but Ba Po is the tame one.
They love to curse.
I would say actually Chinese there's a lot of like different ways you can curse somebody.
Oh yeah.
Yeah like I know like when I was growing up my mom would be like So it's like having a having a pork bun is better than having you.
What?
Wait really?
Wow.
Oh my god.
It's like one of the most common That's what I'm...
Really?
Yes it's a very common It's a very common like Cantonese thing to say.
San ta su ho go san lei.
Do you...
Like I would...
It's pretty tame.
It's tame though.
There's a lot of cursors that have like abbreviations too do you know?
Yeah yeah.
Yeah it's like WD, NMD, SV, then like the chao ni ma is like they also go like WOC for like all those like short form stuff.
Yeah.
Oh yeah yeah.
I actually don't know a lot of the short form stuff cause like I don't know a lot of like the Chinese stuff for like on the internet type deal like internet slang in Chinese.
Like I think like a lot of it was Internet slang.
Yeah.
Yeah a lot of it is like English like like stuff like that in English like cause like I know a lot of the Chinese I learned is also like from movies too.
So like you know like the slang from in movies and stuff but like it's also old movies like Okay I got it.
I don't know like his name in Mandarin but like you know like Zhao Shengqi like Steven Chow and that's his name.
Oh yeah yeah yeah.
Yeah yeah yeah.
So like I would watch like he would say stuff like the the Cantonese slang too.
So like I would like repeat what he would say.
Wait you repeat what he would say?
Okay.
That's where your Chinese Okay I got it.
Wait what do you mean I got it?
Yeah that's where your Chinese is.
He has good really good movies okay.
True.
He has good movies.
Yeah I learned from the best.
Well there's like I think you know enough curse words but like I would say like the short form like I see a lot of like you know like I said earlier like and like NMSL like 你妈死了 and all those like things.
Yeah WDNMD is like 我掉你妈的 or something like that.
Oh yeah yeah.
So they love to like put all those short forms out on the internet and usually you won't understand because it looks like you know like gibberish basically.
Oh Yeah.
But it looks like gibberish?
I mean you won't understand if you don't know Chinese you won't understand at all.
I don't know until I see it.
Yeah but there's like cute ones too.
Wait what are the cute ones?
Yeah I saw like AWSL is actually something really cute like usually yeah a lot of like when I first went to Bilibili they all like used to say that to me all the time.
AWSL is like 啊我死了 in a good way.
啊我死了 啊我死了 No it's like I'm dead but like in a good way.
啊我死了.
You're so cute that I'm dead.
Yeah you're so cute I'm dead.
What?
啊我死了 Oh AWSL Oh wait that's actually really cute.
Yeah a bit from like how cute you are it's actually really cute.
That's so cute actually.
But even your cute words are like morbid you know.
It's like I'm dead.
AWSL and then quote unquote affectionate.
Oh that's actually They like to say like 死了 a lot like 死死了 What is 死死了?
生死的 氣 氣死了 It's like I'm angry to death kind of thing.
Because I'm dead from anger.
Like yeah.
They say a lot of 死了.
I have no idea why though.
Yeah I learned a lot of like this thing.
I learned a lot of like slang.
That's actually so cute.
AWSL that's gonna be my vocabulary now.
I'm just gonna be like AWSL.
AWSL.
It's like TASKARU right?
Yeah that's what I was thinking.
It's like similar to TASKARU.
They like to say KKSK as well.
Kokosuki.
Kokosuki?
What does that mean?
Kokosuki is like I like this point.
In Japanese.
Like TASKARU and KKSK.
Oh.
That's so interesting.
Yeah TSKR and KKSK.
They say KKSK more.
Kokosuki.
Wait what do you guys use for like laughing?
On the internet.
Laughing?
They...
Oh okay they just spam a bunch of itch.
Like just the letter itch.
Or 2333333 The numbers.
Yeah 2333333.
What does that mean?
It's just laughing.
Laughter.
But that's like 2333333.
Okay.
The 23333 thing is like...
I don't know if it's like Bilibili only.
No I don't think it's Bilibili only.
But like it originates something from Bilibili.
It's because like their mascot is called like 2 and 3 or something like that.
If I'm not mistaken.
And like itch itch itch is just hahahaha.
But they just spam like a bunch of itch basically.
Oh yeah so instead of like typing hahahaha it's like itch itch itch itch itch.
Yeah they just spam it.
It's like www you know in Japanese.
Yeah yeah.
They just spam it.
It's like a bunch of w and yeah.
Yeah and they're like hahahaha.
So like for like the Chinese equivalents like hhhhh.
Yeah.
They also spam it.
That's so interesting.
That's really interesting.
Do you guys have anything like like uh like lemow?
So lemow and lol is basically like hhhhh.
Uh...
It's also xiao shi le.
Laugh to death.
It's all... it's all death okay?
Like I don't know.
Like yeah it's just like I just laugh like like.
Laugh to death.
So it's like lemow is like xiao shi le.
It's all short form yeah.
xs... xswl.
Like yeah.
That's so interesting.
Like it's a-a-w-s-l xswl like it's all it they all abbreviate it basically.
Yeah.
I never knew that.
This is what I mean I don't know anything about like like the internet in terms of like like.
He don't know anything.
Okay.
Are you that smart?
I don't.
I am okay you can say that I might be like a a boomer when it comes to like Chinese.
Laugh to death.
I don't know.
I don't know anything to the hip things you know.
Laugh to death.
What do the hip things.
What do the youngins say this time.
Look if I grew up with like teeth and like he's like 50 now.
True.
He's like 50 to 60 now.
And like he hasn't made any I don't know does he has he made new movies I don't know but like I haven't watched any of his new or your movies.
I only know him I think.
Like I'm like wow I I feel like I'm really talking to well.
Like a grandma?
Ayi.
Laugh to death.
Like auntie.
Auntie Doki.
Laugh to death.
Nooo.
I'm young when it comes to like English internet guys.
I swear.
Laugh to death.
Are you just gonna like say all those like like whatever they say now just to appease everybody.
Yeah for sure.
Laugh to death.
Nice job guys.
Not that old.
Laugh to death.
Well.
I swear.
I just don't I just I what do people what do people watch now?
I don't know.
What do people watch in Chinese now?
I just know.
I did it.
I only remember like the old shows what I used to watch like I was growing up.
Like I don't know you don't know this show but like it was like this like variety show.
Um it was like this variety show.
Uh on I think it was on TVB.
And like I like grew up watching and it's like super.
What is that?
It's like this like variety competitions and stuff.
Um with like celebrities and stuff and like that was like I would watch that a lot too.
But that shit is so old.
I don't even know if they still do it anymore.
I've never heard.
What is TVB?
TVB?
So it's like a it's a channel in Hong Kong.
TVB.
So um.
Oh.
Yeah.
I see.
So it's like TVB and Pearl.
I think that was like Pearl would show like the English shows and TVB would be like the Cantonese shows.
Oh yeah Super Trio!
Yeah!
They have a YouTube channel.
I know.
I saw they.
I was watching their YouTube channel and everything.
I was.
Like I grew up watching like a lot of the shows on TVB.
And a lot of the.
And then I would watch like Shuum Hong.
Um.
Like you know like.
Have you ever seen like.
Oh wait no.
Cause you don't watch the old shows.
You know.
Hiro is like the zoomer.
I do feel like a zoomer.
Yeah yeah.
She's like the internet zoomer.
I don't know what she's talking about.
But sounds great.
Have you ever watched like the the Chinese show?
The Shuum Hong.
How do you pronounce that in Mandarin?
Uh.
What's that?
The monkey.
The.
Oh oh.
Xi Wu Ji?
Is that the monkey game?
Yeah!
Okay I watched it on like together with my with my fans.
Oh!
But which version though?
There's so many.
The old one.
The real.
Oh the really famous one?
The 19.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Yeah that one.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Yeah I watched that one.
It's so good!
It is really good.
I like that.
I actually like that.
Yeah and I watched that with my grandpa when I was like growing up like on the TV together.
Oh that's so cute!
Yeah cause they would always have like reruns cause it's so famous.
I did watch it in 1980s guys.
I...
There were reruns!
I would watch the reruns with with my grandpa.
I watched an older one.
I'm not sure.
Was it 19... Yeah it was the 1980s isn't it?
I'm pretty sure right?
Yeah it may be that one.
The most famous one.
I remembered it wrong I think.
But yeah it's the one...
It's the OG one I think.
Yeah.
There's like a new one but I like the I like the old one better.
Yeah yeah.
I think like cause it's a classic too.
It's like a...
I think it's like one of their most...
One of the most famous TV shows Yeah there is like four... It's like the four classics of them.
There's so many.
It's like... It's like That's... COG is one and then San Guo.
San Guo is the other one.
Three Kingdoms?
Yeah yeah.
Sam Goji.
Yeah I love Three Kingdoms.
Oh my god.
I actually visited the temples.
For...
I visited... I visited like Lu Bei's temple.
Because I was like... Wow!
No I was so... I was so obsessed with like Sam Goji.
It was like my life.
I actually read the original book.
Your life?
Yeah no like I actually read the original... You read the book?
Yeah.
I read the original book.
I was like way too young to read that book by the way.
Because it was like...
It's like... It's like two copies and they're like extra thick too.
So...
Because I love the games.
Like the Three Kingdoms... The Dynasty Warrior games.
And through Dynasty Warriors I start... I really liked the stories behind it.
So then I read the books as well.
And then I visited the temples.
Like with my grandpa and my family.
Wow.
Yeah so like I actually went to see like Lu Bei and Zhuge Liang temple.
Crazy.
And...
Yeah.
I heard like Cao Cao temple was recently discovered too.
And like...
Yeah they have a museum.
I really want to go there.
It was like recently discovered.
Because like Cao Cao I don't even know about like the history behind it but like Cao Cao's like temple slash like like... like...
grave was like super hidden and stuff.
So he has like... he has like fake graves.
So people won't like rob it.
And like recently... Wow.
They recently discovered like his actual like tomb.
And...
And people... but like people were like no that can't be his.
That has to be his son.
But people were like no this has to be like Cao Cao's tomb.
Because...
And then so they made like a whole museum based off of it that recently opened.
I think like two years ago or last year.
Wow.
I didn't know that.
Honestly.
I'm like wow.
Really?
I never knew that.
Yeah.
Because I just like watched the...
the...
TV version basically.
Oh there's so many.
Which one did you watch?
I'm like crap.
I can't remember.
Because it was like two, three years ago too already.
I think at this point.
Um... It's just all the old ones.
Basically the OG ones.
The OG ones.
I remember it when... Okay do you see the Red Cliff movie?
Have you ever watched the Red Cliff movie?
It's like... It's like... I watched that at the theaters in China.
Wait.
Isn't it theater?
Yeah.
It's not old.
I'm not... That movie came out not that long.
Okay it came out maybe like ten years ago.
But...
But it's not that... It's not that old.
I haven't even seen that.
I've watched...
I've actually seen that in theaters.
I think like in the first week it came out.
Because like also it's because like the actor that played Ju Geok-leon.
He's like apparently like back then he was like super famous.
And then like my grandma like had a crush on that actor.
So like my grandma like bought like...
My grandma bought me and her and like I think like my dad like VIP seats to like watch the...
Watch the movie.
During like opening.
Wow!
Yeah.
That's actually really interesting.
Like I...
I don't think like my grandparents I don't think they were ever like like watching that many movies actually.
So I never really went to theater like to buy seats or anything.
Have you ever been in a theater in China?
Like a movie theater in China?
No.
Oh my gosh.
I've only gone to China once so far.
It's actually... Wait when did you go to China?
Like when was the last time you went to China?
Recently.
Actually I went...
I went in March.
Oh yeah what did you do?
Wait where did you go?
I went to Shanghai.
Shanghai.
Oh Shanghai.
It's nice.
Yeah I did a 3D I did a 3D live that's why.
Yeah so you went to Shanghai for your 3D?
Yeah I went to their studio.
That's so cool.
Yeah I went to visit the Bidibidi HQ.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
What's it like?
It's actually really cool.
It's actually much nicer like I was kind of scared because you know my mother language is also English and I was like okay my Chinese is like kind of you know you know like okay.
Like hmmm.
I was like kind of scared going there but like it was actually really nice like it was really interesting.
Oh.
That's really cool though.
You get to see their headquarters.
It's pretty English friendly so I was like okay.
Thank God.
It's like if I don't understand they'll speak English.
That's really sweet.
But like have you ever been to like a theatre in China right?
Like a movie theatre?
No I've not gone to a theatre.
It's actually really nice cause like I think like the seats are I think like back then when I went to the movie theatre like back then in N.A.
you don't have like seats reservations in N.A.
So it's like in N.A.
when you wanna go to a movie theatre.
I think now people can reserve seats but back then like when I was a lot younger it was like a battle royale for like getting I'm getting good seats.
Really?
Yeah, it was like you have to get there early if you want to have good seats.
It's like a free-for-all.
So people would have to actually get to the theaters early just to watch it.
If it was a really good movie and people really want to watch it, if you don't get there early, you have to sit at the very front or something.
But I don't know now.
Honestly, I haven't been to a movie theater for a long time.
Anyway, I remember when I started to live in Asia and in China too.
When I first came to the theater, I was like, oh my god, you get to reserve seats?
You mean I don't have to come to the theater 30 minutes early just to sit in a good spot?
I'm getting convinced you're becoming like grandma.
That's so true!
I'm seeing it.
I'm like, wait, really?
What you're saying is, I'm like, wait, really?
No, it's true!
Look, I came from a place where there was a battle royale for movie seats.
There's some straddle.
But then also, I think now they have buttered popcorn.
But I remember popcorn back then was only caramel popcorn back then.
But I don't know.
I don't know what that means.
I don't know.
All the parents and grandmas and grandpas say they were like...
Even when they go anywhere, they always say it's like they went on like a journey.
It's so difficult to do anything.
Yeah!
Even going to the movie theater is like, whoa.
It's a VR.
That's true.
But I remember there's like the VIP movie theaters too.
Where, like, Oh my gosh, where there's only like 15 seats or whatever, like 15 chairs.
And they're all like recliners.
This is... it's true!
I went to like... my grandma was like... loves movies.
And then like... and then because like I was like...
So like in Chinese culture, like I was like the...
The first born grandchild with like the... the last name.
Because I wasn't the first born grandchild technically.
Because I had like cousins older than me.
But I was the first one that came from... that has like...
My last name was like basically like the last name of my grandparents.
So like... so then they... like they were like, okay, we have VIP movie tickets.
We take doki to the...
So I get to like... I get to like...
So I was like considered like the favorite child.
The favorite grandchild.
Because of it.
The favorite what?
Yeah.
Favorite child?
The... the favorite grandchild.
And the first born perks.
And then... and then so like I got to do like the...
I got to... I got to do like...
The VIP movie theaters.
And it was crazy because like...
First off like the chairs are recliners.
And then... and then like...
And then like you don't have to go to the...
You don't have to go to like... to outside to order the food.
You can just order like...
There's like movie theater tenants that come to you and be like, what do you...
It's like a flight attendant.
They'll be like, what do you want to eat?
And then they'll be like, okay, I'll have this and that.
And they'll like go... and then they'll like make it and they'll bring it to you.
And...
Yeah, back then this is like...
This is like crazy already.
Like and then like a lot of like...
And it's not like...
A lot of like the bigger movie theaters had like a VIP section too.
But it was like...
So yeah, I watched the Red Cliff on the VIP movie theaters.
Are you flexing?
Like... I'm like listening.
Favorite grandchild.
VIPC.
The Red Cliff was a good movie!
It was so good!
It deserved to be in the VIP section.
I wish I was the favorite grandchild.
It was nice.
And then like...
And then I like...
And I remember I went back to Canada and then at the movie theaters was still...
Still the Battle Royale.
Now tell that story in Chinese.
Okay, then...
I was young back then.
I...
That's Cantonese!
Okay, my Cantonese is...
I can listen.
I can understand.
But like...
I can't speak at all, I think.
I can only listen a little bit.
Wait, wait, wait.
Say sentence in Cantonese.
What is like...
Do you know a sentence in Cantonese?
I just said I can't speak it at all.
You did, but you said you know a little bit.
You said you know a little bit.
I can listen.
Yeah.
I only know memes, basically.
Wait.
Like what memes?
I don't even know the memes.
Uh...
三點幾 落 飲茶先啊 That meme?
Wait, what is that?
Do you know that?
No, I just know like...
You don't know?
No, what is that meme?
There's like a video.
I think it's on VidiVidi if I'm not mistaken.
Yeah, it's like...
It's like...
It's 3pm.
Like...
Just have some...
Yeah, yeah.
Have some time.
Yeah!
Like the only meme I know is the one more thing.
It was like, when they reanimated some...
I think it was like some Cantonese movie into a beaver.
Like that's the only meme I know.
You know that one?
Wait, what is that?
You don't know the beaver?
The beaver video meme?
Like somebody...
It was like some super passionate speech in Cantonese.
And then they like reanimated it into a beaver.
Like...
Like what?
The dramatic beaver!
You were?
Yeah!
Wait, you don't... you never heard of that one?
Send it to me.
Wait, okay.
I think it's because it got so...
Like, was it in Cantonese or Mandarin?
I don't remember.
But I just remember it got so...
Oh, it was in Cantonese?
Sorry.
Auntie Doki's memory is not as good as it used to be.
Wait, then what was it in?
It's because like... okay.
It's because like... it was... that meme got so popular apparently that it transcended overseas.
So like people overseas were like, what is this?
They couldn't understand what he was saying.
They were like, wait, this is pretty funny.
But they didn't understand what the beaver was saying.
So that's what I knew about.
Just because like it went overseas.
I'll show you.
I kind of want to...
Okay.
Let me see if I can find...
Let me see if I can find Chinese beaver.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
See?
It's the original Cantonese.
I knew it.
It's a better tomorrow.
Is this Cantonese?
Yeah, it was in Cantonese.
I fucking knew it.
I was like... I knew it because like I could understand most of what they were saying.
It was this one.
I've never seen this in my whole life.
You've never seen that one?
I've never seen it.
Why does he have like a wound on his face?
It's because it was like reanimated from the actual movie.
It was like his persona or something.
Like...
Yeah, it got... it literally has 2.3 million views.
Because people like overseas were like, what is this?
People were like, wait, is this funny?
I don't know what he's saying, but this is so funny.
Like...
Yeah, there's like subtitles so I can kind of get it.
Yeah, so it's like... it's based off...
Yeah.
Wait, I'll show you the original clip.
This is... it's based off...
Yeah.
This is the original clip.
I've... I've never seen this.
You've never seen this one?
No, I've never seen this.
Maybe it was like not that popular like in like the Chinese internet culture.
Well, I... I was never...
You know, I didn't know Chinese for like a long time.
Yeah, but this was 3 months ago.
Maybe you never looked at it.
This is 3 months ago.
3 months ago?
Yeah, this is 3 months ago.
I've never seen it.
This is 3 months ago.
Maybe it's just because like...
This is not Grab-a-me.
Maybe there's like different things...
Maybe...
I don't know.
Like I've never seen this.
Guys, this is not a Grab-a-me.
It's literally 3 months ago.
This is from...a 1986 movie.
Yes, but the meme was 3 months ago!
That's not ancient!
You sure?
I...
That's not ancient!
The meme might be old, but the meme is young!
The meme is young!
Hm -mmm...
Maybe the memes are made by all the aunties.
No!
All the grandmas and grandpas.
I don't want to be naive.
No!
I don't want to.
Take your 1986 movie and put it as a meme.
I don't even know how to say young in Chinese.
Young.
I am young.
God,
I'm so scared.
I'm like, okay, I pray to God.
I'm saying the correct word.
Because my pronunciation is crap.
Sometimes I'm so scared.
It's not as bad as me.
Really?
Of course, yeah.
It's not as bad as me.
Because you're actually practicing.
Speaking Chinese too.
I'm not.
My pronunciation has deteriorated a lot over the years.
Because I'm mostly speaking English now.
Have you ever learned...
You play Apex.
I play Apex, right?
Yeah.
Have you ever learned the Apex characters' Chinese names?
You taught me some of them.
I remember you taught me...
What was it?
The Charger iPhone?
Yeah.
Zibong?
Zibong.
Yeah.
You taught me.
And I remember you taught me...
You tried to teach me the other names.
And then I forgot.
The new character...
I was telling you.
I streamed 16 hours of YouTube.
Yeah.
The new character speaks Cantonese.
No.
Yeah.
Because I didn't know that.
And then she suddenly started...
She was like, dun dun.
And I was like...
Yeah.
She scared me.
I was like...
Wait.
Was that Cantonese?
I was like...
She was like...
Dun dun.
And I was like...
I was like...
Wait.
I understood her.
She was like suddenly aware.
And I was like...
Oh my god.
Wait.
I know what she's saying.
Yeah.
I was so surprised.
Actually, do you know...
Conduit?
Conduit's Chinese name is kind of like...
The first time I learned it, everyone was telling me it was a bad word, by the way, in Chinese.
Really?
I don't know if you understand.
I call her Tao Guan.
Tao Guan.
Wait.
What does that mean?
I don't know that word.
It's like apparently...
Okay.
It's apparently...
Like masturbation or something like that.
Wow.
Yeah.
And that's her Chinese name.
So I was like...
So when I first...
I was like...
I don't know.
Yeah.
So when I first learned it, I was like...
Why is it a bad word?
You know?
I was like...
Oh my god.
Yeah.
That's why I was like...
I was like...
But when I'm learning all like the legends names, I'm like...
Yeah.
Wait.
Why is this guy called this?
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Do you know Octane's...
No, it's Octane's.
...
nickname?
Octane's nickname in Chinese is...
Bye.
白鴿小子 白鴿小子 白鴿...
Do you know what 白鴿 is?
I don't know what that is, but the other one is like kid.
Right?
Yeah.
白鴿 is like...
white...
white to give.
It's like...
white flag.
You know, it's like...
he's like...
Oh, like giving up?
Like surrender?
No, he basically just...
just...
stims and dies all the time.
Oh!
So they call it like...
白鴿 It's called 白鴿 in Chinese.
白鴿小子 That's funny.
Stims and dies.
Yeah.
That's what you name.
They just call him like...
Like feeder type of...
Because his name is 東立小子 actually.
東立小子 But then they call him 白鴿小子 now.
Yeah.
They're like...
They give like nicknames.
Yeah.
He eats all the time.
He's just...
He just like...
He just goes and dies.
You know?
Yeah.
That's so good.
Unfortunately.
Yeah.
It's such a good name.
There is...
Caustic.
Yeah, yeah.
It's like fireman.
It's...
I remember.
Ewww!
I can't remember.
Yeah.
偶南 Pman.
What?
偶南 偶南 Oh, yeah.
偶南 I like how that was the one I remember.
I was like, Oh my God.
I remember this.
Because this name was the most like...
Fucked up.
I was like fartman.
Yeah.
I really like to like...
Like learn their name.
偶南 It's really weird.
You know, it's like...
Yeah.
Weird but you kind of get it.
It's like slang names.
Like nicknames and stuff.
That's so interesting.
I was like...
Bloodhound is just dog.
It's like...
Oh, it's called...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dog man.
It's really funny.
It's really literal actually in Chinese.
Yeah, yeah.
I think like...
I remember I read something about like...
the nicknames they have for different things.
It's always like... it's interesting.
Yeah, it's like...
literal I think a lot of times.
It's very literal too.
Gosh, I wish... there's like...
There was like a popular...
I don't remember if it was like a gamer show where they were like...
They were giving nicknames too.
But I always find it very interesting.
Like the type of nicknames that come up.
Like the Chinese nicknames they come up with.
Because sometimes it's like...
really fucking funny.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I really like it.
I watch a little bit of like...
the talk show and all that.
Sometimes just to learn.
Yeah, I really like it as well.
It's funny.
I miss... I miss...
I miss watching like...
Like Chinese...
like variety shows.
Because there's like some really funny ones.
Like when I was growing up.
Okay, this is not...
Oh, true, true.
But have you ever heard... I always talk about this one to my chat.
But have you ever heard about the one where like...
It's like a bunch of...
women.
Like with buttons and stuff.
And then one guy comes out.
And like he has to like talk about like his life.
And like why he is like the perfect...
He can be like the perfect boyfriend.
Slash husband.
And then like he gets judged by like...
a panel of women.
And then like there'll be like videos playing about his life.
And then one by one women will like...
press the button as in like...
No, he's not the perfect guy for me.
Like reject him.
I've never seen that.
That show was so popular.
I don't know if it's still like...
Does the stat show still goes on?
Dating show?
Yeah, it was a dating show.
But it was like so popular.
It was like really popular back then.
I don't know if it still is.
Dating?
I haven't watched like a dating show in so long.
Yeah, but it's like some...
Okay, to be honest.
It was like a show that like...
parents love to watch.
And then I would watch it with them.
It was like the parent show.
Like every parent...
Like every parent would watch it.
Really?
Yeah, no it's true.
My child was like...
Oh my god, my mom watches that show all the time.
It was true.
See, my dad loves that show.
I think you're exposing your dick.
I didn't watch it willingly.
It was on tape.
On TV.
Okay, I did watch it willingly because I could choose not to watch it with my parents.
But it was interesting.
It was funny.
Because sometimes it was like...
Sometimes it was like...
The guy would be like...
Really not a good person.
Really?
He would be like...
Like an extra deadbeat.
But he would be on the show.
And then you would see a panel of women...
Just be like...
Pressing the button.
And then he would be like...
And then you would see a panel of women...
Just be like...
Pressing the button.
And then you would be like...
All of them rejecting it.
What is the show called?
It was so popular.
Yes, the host was a bald man.
Yes, I remember the host.
He's so famous.
He's super fucking rich now.
Because that show made him really famous.
Because he was such a good host.
Can you not read it?
Somebody wrote it.
What does that say?
What is it?
In my chat.
I can't read it.
I told you I can't read.
I can't read this.
I can't really...
I've never heard of that in my life.
You've never heard of that show?
It's famous!
Wait, what kind of Chinese shows do you know?
That's not old.
I don't know.
I don't know Chinese shows that are old.
Doesn't your chat recommend you some shows to watch?
Mostly...
It's not really...
How do I put it?
It's mostly like the...
They recommend the really old one.
Wait, you can't call it old.
You can't call me old.
Your chat recommends these things to you.
They're recommending me like classic...
classical stuff, you know?
Yeah, and I'm like...
Watch the classical stuff.
Because I'm cultured.
You watch classical and like...
And what?
We never recommend you any like...
I'm going to VIP theater.
Okay.
Look.
It's classy.
Okay.
Wait, what kind of shows does your chat recommend you?
Honestly...
They don't recommend me...
They recommend me some...
But I don't really look for them...
for recommendations or shows.
Because it's more...
You don't trust your chat.
I...
It's because...
I mostly watch the ones...
that they already recommend me.
And it's only the classical ones.
Because they don't really watch...
TV shows, you know?
Wait, what do they watch?
They only watch...
People nowadays, they watch...
You know, they watch movies still.
But most people just look at videos all the time.
Oh, like...
So it's just like...
It's just like NA...
where people don't watch shows anymore.
They just watch streamers...
and YouTube videos.
Do you think...
VTuber...
Honestly, they watch more anime...
I think.
There's like...
Chinese animation is really good now too.
I heard.
Yeah.
Okay.
There are some really good Chinese animations.
But...
Mostly everyone still watches them.
I think it's because...
VTuber is actually...
Do you know...
VTuber was like...
Miku fans...
At first...
Everyone is...
It's called Miku fans or something.
Miku has always been super crazy...
popular worldwide.
It's like an otaku...
Basically...
Everyone there is anime fan.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
So they mostly watch...
into...
anime stuff.
But there are still a lot of people that watch like...
TV, talk shows and all those things.
It's just that they don't really recommend it to me.
Since like...
I don't think I...
watch that many as well.
Oh, so you're saying you might not like...
like it as much as they do.
I don't understand I think.
And it's like the way they talk...
and speaking wise might be like...
It's difficult.
It's because they talk really fast.
It's like fluent so...
it might be harder to understand.
That's true.
I did not understand what was going on in that...
dating show but like...
From what I could like...
peace out from the words...
I do understand.
It seemed really funny.
Yeah.
Talk shows are just too...
fast.
They talk...
extremely fast.
Like back and forth kind of thing.
It's really difficult.
But like I try sometimes.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
Do you know...
like what is like...
basically otaku in Chinese?
Wait, what is otaku in Chinese?
Er Ci Yan.
Er Ci Yan?
Yeah, it's like...
like... how do I...
put it like...
There is... Zhai Nan is like...
Zhai Nan.
There is Zhai Nan in Chinese.
But that's mostly like...
I would say Er Ci Yan is more accurate.
Er Ci Yan.
What does that mean?
Er Ci Yan?
Er Ci... Er Ci is...
Er Ci is...
two, right?
Er...
What's Ci Yan?
I only know it in Japanese.
Wait, I'm trying to translate it in English in my brain.
It's not working.
It means 2D.
Oh, 2D.
Yeah, it's like...
like... like... like... like...
Oh...
I see.
2D.
2D is the best.
It's true.
Yeah.
Because we're 2D.
And we're pretty cool.
Are you?
Actually, are you?
And I'm pretty young.
I'm very young.
I'm not an auntie.
Okay, are you like into...
You're a Vtuber, but are you...
Are you Er Ci Yan?
Okay, to be fair, I'm like...
Okay, I always tell in my chat this, but I'm actually like really normie.
Like...
Normie?
Yeah, I'm actually very normie.
Um...
Because like I actually watch 3D shows.
Like, you know, flesh...
Fleshed shows.
Of people that are like flesh and not 2D.
I actually don't watch a lot of anime.
To be fair.
Um...
But it's only because... Yeah.
But it's only because like...
Because like I like to watch subs, not dubs.
So like I watch... So like I have to read it.
And I don't have the time to like just sit down and watch anime type deal.
Like I... If I'm watching a show, I always do something in the background while I'm watching something.
So like... So I can like split my attention like I can just like... If I...
I don't have to look at the screen all the time.
I can just like listen to what they're saying.
And also like, you know, do stuff.
So like I think like... Other than like...
I think... I'm trying to think of like the last anime I've watched.
Oh my god.
Don't tell me like a 1980 anime.
No, no, no.
I do watch the new stuff.
But it's like only if it's like super... Like you know, it's like the most popular thing on the internet type deal.
Because I watch...
I try to watch like 2 episodes of Oshinoko.
And then I stopped after 2 episodes because I got depressed.
Oh, yeah.
Actually, Oshinoko...
I actually also like...
I've watched... I spoiled myself a bit and I was...
I was like, okay, okay, I can't read this.
It's really... It's kind of sad.
It's kind of depressing.
It's too real.
Yeah.
So like I stopped and then like... I think that was like the last anime I've watched.
But like I would watch like, you know, like Oh, My Hero Academia was so popular.
Like I mean, I guess it's so popular.
But I would watch... I think I watched like the first season of My Hero Academia when it first came out.
And then like... Oh, like Demon Slayer was so popular.
So I watched the first season of Demon Slayer when it came out.
And then like...
Oh, JJK is currently so popular.
So I watched the first season.
I am!
I am mainstream!
I like watch it.
It's just extremely mainstream.
I am!
It's like all the things you're listening is the... hmm... okay.
Yeah, I told you!
Ignore me!
I just watch the mainstream!
I told you!
I don't watch... I just watch the mainstream stuff.
The only time I've like gone out to watch like things that weren't mainstream or like read stuff that weren't mainstream.
It was like years ago I feel like.
Um... but like some of my favorite... like I don't know if you ever heard of the Liar Game.
That's like one of my favorite like non-mainstream.
I've heard of.
Yeah, I probably have.
It's basically cause like Death Note is like one of my favorite like manga slash anime of all time.
Like I love... Okay, you say... okay Death Note is nice.
It's cool.
What do you mean nice?
The way you...
Yeah, it's nice.
You know what?
I give you a point for that.
I'm like... in my head I'm like...
Okay, I gotta like count everything.
Everything that she said before.
It's like...
It is like a work of art.
But I honestly I love like everything.
Like I love the writer and the illustrator like when they work together.
Like I love everything they do together.
So like I've read like almost everything they've done.
Like after Death Note.
Um... like Bakuman.
I love Bakuman.
Um... I don't know if you've heard of Bakuman.
It's like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have.
Yeah, it's like...
Yeah, it's the one where like they... it was like basically like parodying like Shonen Jump and like what it's like to be a manga writer and illustrator.
So like I watched...
Like I love...
I love Bakuman and I love Death Note.
But like...
Yeah, Death Note was like my favorite all time favorite.
I think it was like...
Like before Death Note, I didn't really care about anime and manga.
Like I was like super normie where I didn't even care.
Other than like the shows that like my parents grew up with.
Because like my parents grew up with like Dr. Slump and like um...
IQ... IQ Bossy.
Dr. Slump.
Okay IQ Bossy.
And then like uh...
Uh... Oh my god.
And then Shin-chan.
You know Shin-chan right?
Shin -chan is so fucking fun.
Yeah.
I'm like listening to you list off the anime.
I know it's old.
But my parents grew up with it.
So like...
You know how like they grew up with it so they had the DVDs and the manga and then so they gave it to me to watch.
And they gave it to me to watch so I watched it growing up.
So like...
And then there's like oh yeah Chibi...
Maruko-chan.
Oh my god that's so old.
That's actually old old.
I actually did watch Chibi.
I think Chibi Maruko I watched.
Yeah Chibi Maruko.
I think it's cause the opening too.
You remember the opening?
That shit was fire.
You know the opening?
I was too young to remember.
What are you talking about?
I'm like...
It's a good opening.
It's like kind of like...
You know the opening to that?
No there's like...
Okay wait no there was like a...
Peely bada peely bada...
Yeah that part.
It was just so catchy.
That one is like...
I think even now a lot of people still know it.
Exactly!
It doesn't mean I'm old!
That's the only part though.
Peely bada peely bada...
It's a good opening!
Yeah Suyinji.
Oh yeah yeah that's what it's called.
Suyinji.
Cause I only knew like the name.
I knew the name in Cantonese.
But I didn't know the name.
I forgot the name in like Japanese.
And then Taimo.
Your Cantonese is really great right now.
No.
Like it's better than your Chinese.
I would say so cause like...
I speak Cantonese at home.
I don't speak Mandarin.
I don't speak like Chinese Mandarin.
Because like only my dad knows how to speak Mandarin.
But then like...
He like refused to teach me Mandarin when I was growing up.
Because he was like...
You don't need to know Mandarin.
You just need to know Cantonese.
And then he was like...
Dude.
She's gonna get confused.
If we teach her more than one.
So we'll just...
We'll just speak in Cantonese.
So I never...
Only when I started getting older.
And like...
And when I moved overseas.
That like I started to learn like Mandarin.
Because like people around me were speaking Mandarin.
And I'm like...
Why didn't you teach me Mandarin dad?
I was just like...
Everybody's speaking Mandarin.
Why did you not teach me?
It's like...
All my extended family on my dad's side...
Speaks Mandarin.
And they'll like tell me stuff.
And I'll be like...
Maybe they did try when you were like really young.
You like feel...
Yeah I couldn't like absorb it.
Like we give up.
They're like...
Oh no she's too stupid.
We'll just go with one.
But your accent.
Your accent like...
Speaking Mandarin and Cantonese.
Like Chinese and Cantonese now is like pretty good isn't it?
Like...
No I feel like it's worse because...
Like I don't know.
I don't use it as often anymore.
Like I think you're definitely better.
Because you speak it more fluently than me.
I feel...
And you're like...
I'm always like embarrassed sometimes.
Because it's like...
You know I'm really scared.
It's like the 口音 is like always there.
You know 口音?
Wait what's 口音?
The accent is always there.
Oh!
And you didn't like grow up.
I think you didn't like naturally like grow up.
I knew English and Japanese though.
It's like...
When I was learning Chinese and all that.
It was really difficult actually.
Really difficult.
Right now like when I'm speaking.
Like when I see 聽不懂.
I'm like...
聽不懂!
Oh no!
Did I just say that really badly or something?
Hahaha.
Sometimes I'm scared too.
Because I'm like...
Oh no what if I pronounce something wrong?
Ever since in high school.
When my friends laughed at me for speaking Cantonese.
I...
Oh yeah.
Trauma.
Real trauma.
I'm like...
Oh my god!
She finally spoke Chinese in the I try to speak Chinese stream.
Should we try and speak in Chinese?
It only took an hour and 30 minutes.
Let's try.
Yeah.
My Chinese is a little...
Like a child.
Oh I'm a child too.
Hahaha.
I am.
Wait a minute.
You feel like you can...
If your...
Your Chinese is...
Can you read some comments?
Huh?
Hahaha.
Sorry I don't know what you're saying.
I know a little bit of what you're saying.
I don't know what you're...
Hahaha.
I don't know what you're saying.
Okay.
I only heard like...
Half of it.
Hahaha.
I'm like...
I want to show you...
I want to teach you...
Some really...
Funny meme.
But it's like...
Really difficult.
Do you know there's Chinese memes?
But it's very difficult to understand.
There's a difference between...
English type of memes...
Versus the China Chinese type of memes.
Like what?
Like they have...
Abstract kind of memes.
Do you know there's something about...
Do you know there's a place in China...
Called Guangdong?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've been there.
That's where they speak a lot of Cantonese.
And like...
Apparently there's a lot of cockroaches over there.
Huh?
I just recently learned this too.
I was like...
Wait, what?
There's a lot of cockroaches there?
And there's a meme where they say...
Because there's so many cockroaches there...
They have a meme saying...
Guangdong cockroaches are worried about you.
It's like...
The Guangdong cockroaches are worried for you.
And they have a picture of the cockroaches at the window.
It's really stupid.
Yeah.
That's funny.
Wait, do you have a picture of that?
Or is it just like a verbal thing?
I think I do.
But I need to find it.
It's like...
It's a really weird picture.
It's just a cockroach looking.
Looking at a window basically.
It's like...
I was like...
I remember the giant cockroaches.
Oh my god.
I remember too.
I'll find it.
Oh my god.
I remember like...
Because like in Shenzhen.
Shenzhen.
I used to live in Shenzhen.
And like...
I remember like...
I told a story before.
A long time ago.
But like...
I was getting ready for school.
And then like...
I was about to leave.
And I felt something hit my head.
I was like...
And I shook my head.
And then I looked down.
And I saw a fucking giant cockroach.
Like between my feet.
And then I freaked out.
And I screamed.
I went back home.
I was just like at the...
You know like...
Actually I don't know if you know.
But in Chinese homes.
There's like two layers.
You go out but it's not outside yet.
It's not outside your home yet.
It's not backyard because it's like an apartment.
Villa thing.
You go out but there's a balcony.
And you have to go out again.
So like...
So I went out.
And then...
I didn't go out out.
I went out.
And I ran back inside.
And I took a shower and everything.
I was late for school.
But I couldn't.
I was like...
It touched me.
Are you scared of cockroaches?
No I'm scared of every type of bug.
I'm scared of every type of bug.
I got slapped by a giant moth at one point.
When I was walking down.
Oh my gosh.
Where was this place?
It was like...
I remember one time I took a school trip to...
Oh my gosh.
I'm trying to remember where that place is in China.
But we were walking down this...
Me and my friends were just walking down this pathway.
And a giant fucking moth just slapped me in the face.
I was like...
Yeah I think that was scary.
I was so scared.
I'm lucky.
Yeah it was scary.
I'm scared of like...
Lizards.
Lizards?
Why are you scared of lizards?
I think it's PTSD as well.
Wait what is the PTSD?
It's like...
So there was a time when I was younger.
And I stayed alone.
When I was a little kid already.
I had my own room basically.
My parents would be staying in another room.
And...
It was dark in the room.
I was trying to turn on the light.
But I was kind of small and short.
So I was reaching for a really high light switch.
And when I turned it on.
I felt something like...
Drop on my arm in the dark.
And I was like...
I was like...
What the hell is that?
And when I turned on the light.
I saw a lizard on my hand.
I freaked out and I screamed.
And I threw it on my bed.
And then like...
It disappeared.
Under my covers or something.
And I was like...
I stood there and I was like...
Oh crap.
Oh my god.
There's a lizard in my bed.
Because I was like a little kid.
I was like 6 or 7.
Yeah yeah.
Oh my god.
It's so scary.
I was like...
Oh no.
There's a lizard in my bed.
What do I do?
I can't sleep here anymore.
And I cried because I was so scared.
Because it was on my bed.
And on my hand.
And I just froze it.
So I cried.
And I cried and called for my parents.
But the thing is...
My parents were watching TV or something.
And they thought that I was laughing.
Instead of crying.
So I was like crying.
Calling for my mom.
And she was like...
Why is she laughing so hard?
Oh my god.
They thought I was laughing.
So I stood there crying.
I was like... Why aren't my parents coming?
I'm like...
I'm crying here.
And then like...
Then they called for me.
They were like...
What's so funny?
I'm crying.
I'm not laughing.
I didn't sleep in that bed for like 2 weeks.
I slept with my parents.
For like 2 weeks.
I've had that moment before.
I think it was like...
I don't know.
It was like...
I've had these moments where like...
If I see a bug...
In a room.
I just never go back to that room.
For like...
For like 1-2 weeks.
I just never go back to that room.
I remember like...
When I was younger.
I think I saw like a spider or something.
In the bathroom.
And then for 1-2 weeks.
I just used my parents bathroom.
Because I was like...
I'm not going.
I was like...
What if it comes back?
Like spiders?
Speaking of spiders...
I've been like...
I don't know why.
Currently...
I stream in a separate room from my...
Sleeping.
My bed is in another room.
I have like 3D cameras set up.
I have like home 3D set up.
In the other streaming room.
And like...
There's a spider in here somewhere.
Actually.
And...
It only comes out when I play Apex.
And I have no idea why.
What?
Apex?
It has disturbed me like...
I think 4 times so far.
When I'm streaming as well.
Only when I'm streaming by the way.
And like...
During other times when I'm streaming other things.
It does not even bother me at all.
But like when I'm playing Apex.
I'm like fighting a team.
It'll suddenly come in front of me.
Like it'll hang in front of me.
Or it'll drop on my lap.
And I'm like crap this is a spider.
And I have to like AFK you know.
And sometimes I'm like dead.
I'm like basically a death box.
Oh my god.
It's just like...
It only comes...
Yeah I had no idea why.
The spider just enjoys the gameplay.
So I don't know what to play.
It's been like bothering me.
I even have like a spray now.
Because it's going crazy.
But it's still alive?
Yeah!
I don't know maybe it had like a wife.
I don't know.
Wait don't say that.
Because then there could be multiple spiders now.
That's scary.
Oh sorry.
Speaking of which there was.
Recently.
It was like my most recent spider encounter.
There's two.
There was two of them.
I remember.
And I was freaking out because there's two of them.
I was like.
Why are there two of them?
Yeah I was scared.
But oh well.
I'm not that scared of spiders.
It's okay.
I'm not that.
I think spiders.
It's okay if there's two of them.
That means it might be two females.
Or two males.
Because I think the female eats the male spider.
If they're after.
So if you find out there's one spider left.
Then maybe you should get worried.
Yeah.
Oh.
Just maybe after.
There's one spider left.
That means it ate.
The male spider.
Yeah.
Well.
But you're scared of bugs right?
I'm okay actually.
I'm pretty okay with bugs.
It's just if they are on me.
Then I kind of like don't want them on me.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
If it gets really bad.
I remember I used to sleep with a mosquito net.
When I was younger.
I would have like.
You know like the nets that would go over your bed.
Yeah.
I only use it once I think.
When I was growing up in Asia.
I used it a lot.
Because my blood was apparently really delicious.
So then I would get bit very often.
Yeah.
So for those who don't know.
Chat.
Mosquitoes only target you if you have really delicious blood.
It's like a particular blood type.
I don't know what blood type I am.
Because I never found out.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Maybe there's a record somewhere.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't know what my blood type is.
So like you get bit a lot.
It's because your blood type is like.
A particular blood type that mosquitoes really really like.
And so like I had to like.
I had like mosquito nets.
And then I would wear these like.
Bracelets.
That was like mosquito repellent bracelets.
And stuff.
And then I would like have to spray myself.
With repellent every fucking day.
Because if I don't.
I scratch a lot.
Yeah.
I couldn't help myself.
I would scratch myself a lot.
I think I'm pretty similar.
If I'm not mistaken.
Well I don't think they bite me that much.
But they used to bite me as well.
Like I'm.
But I'm like O.
I don't remember if it's O.
It's the one that can give blood to everyone.
The O that gives blood to everyone.
Yeah blood type O is universal.
Yeah.
But there's like O minus O.
I would like.
I don't know which one it is.
I know like my dad's blood is even more delicious.
Than mine.
So then like I remember like when we go on trips.
Like we would just stick with my dad.
So then all the mosquitoes would bite my dad.
Instead of me.
That was like.
You get like a meat shield.
So then the mosquitoes would target one person.
Wow.
Even as a kid.
It's true.
My mom taught me that.
Your mom taught you that?
Yeah.
I was like stick with dad.
His blood is more delicious.
It wasn't my idea.
Your mom is.
Yeah she taught you well.
Doesn't she watch your stream?
Yeah she does.
She's so cute.
Like family watching stream.
Yeah so do you wanna say something?
I don't curse words?
Woah woah woah.
I didn't expect.
I was so scared that we were gonna speak like full chinese the entire time.
Oh yeah that's true.
Somebody in my chat was like the worst part was when they fly around your ears.
Oh I hate that.
I hate that so much.
When the mosquitoes fly around your ear.
I could never sleep.
If I hear a mosquito I just don't sleep.
Really?
You know when the mosquitoes fly and it's like...
And it's like so high pitched too.
And then I get super paranoid too.
Cause I was like...
Oh no he wants my blood.
Or she wants my blood.
I can't sleep until she's dead.
Oh yeah.
Yeah I rarely hear...
Actually I think my room...
I keep like a can.
Like basically a bug spray.
Nearby in case.
Yeah.
Yeah I do have one.
So I regularly make sure it's like...
Yeah.
I would like have like...
I think like later on.
Cause it got really bad.
So I had the mosquito zapper.
You know the blue light.
And I would just sleep with the blue light on.
And it would be like...
Yeah I think I bought a racket once.
Oh no.
I'm too fucking scared to use the racket.
Cause it's like too close.
Cause you know there's like...
Cause then you're swinging it.
And then like the fly wing...
The mosquito wings come off.
Cause you're zapping it.
And I'm like oh I don't want it near me.
So I just have like...
I bought the mosquito zapper.
And I put it on the ground.
And it would be like...
I think the scariest shit is like...
You know when you open the window.
And you have the mosquito...
Screen.
You know like the screen that you push up.
So like you don't let the mosquitoes in.
But you can have like outside air come in.
And then you just see like...
Like the mosquitoes just fucking...
Be like let me in.
That's just...
I never open the window.
Like I would never open the window.
Because I just see like...
All the mosquitoes outside be like...
Let us in.
Like I would never open the window.
Like maybe it's where...
Like the area you lived in had like a lot of mosquitoes.
Oh no no I lived...
I lived in an area...
I remember like growing up.
We would always live in areas with a lot of trees.
And like grass and everything.
So...
So I would always...
I would see the mosquitoes outside and be like...
Let us in.
Oh...
Yeah like...
The area I lived in...
They did like regular fogging basically.
Yeah.
Yeah because you know it's...
Pretty disgusting like all the mosquitoes.
So they do like fogging all the time.
Oh that's...
I didn't need to use any nets.
Oh my god.
Because I only used it like once ever.
That's so nice.
Everywhere I lived...
Like when I lived in Asia because I moved around a lot.
Everywhere I lived there were so many mosquitoes.
Because there was so much nature around us.
Well it's not even nature.
It was like...
Sometimes I would live in like a mini gated community.
Because I would...
At one point I lived with my grandparents.
And they lived in a gated community.
And then like...
But like...
There was like a park and then there was trees around us.
And everything.
So there was a lot of mosquitoes.
And then there was cicadas too.
So I could hear them go like...
Oh that's so annoying.
I had one in my room.
You know like I had...
Okay it was in the wall somewhere.
What?
It was in the wall?
How did it get there?
I think it went through like a pipe or something.
I don't know.
But like it was so noisy.
So I...
On Bidipidi they have like an app for your phone.
And you can do phone stream by the way.
It's like...
I think YouTube you can do phone stream.
You can use your...
I can use my live 2D in that app.
Basically.
It's like a customized app or something.
And I was trying to do a phone stream in my room.
Like just with live 2D.
And like...
Basically everybody could hear...
the cicada.
Oh the cicada going like...
Yeah it was really loud.
Like at night I couldn't sleep by the way.
It was so noisy.
Like it was just constantly...
making noise at night.
And it was so difficult to sleep actually.
Oh my god.
It was so close as well.
It was like right above my bed.
Like somewhere you know in those pipes.
Yeah yeah.
Oh my god.
What is he doing?
How did he survive for so long?
Aren't you hungry?
Yeah it was so long.
I was like looking out.
When do cicadas die?
How old is your life span?
I was like...
I was wondering because I was like...
This guy has been here for so long.
And I was like losing sleep over it.
So I was like...
I was going crazy.
I was like please just die.
I can't take it already.
It was really difficult.
How long did it live for?
Well a while.
Until like...
Yeah I was like...
hitting my wall because occasionally...
if I slam my door hard enough...
it would like shut up for a bit.
It was like what's that?
Yeah.
So I had to...
slam my door like...
when I'm going out of my room.
I would just close it really hard.
And it would shut up for like 10-15 minutes.
And I would be like...
peace and quiet.
Oh my god.
That cicada was just like...
Who is invading my home?
The cicada must be like...
Who is this girl?
What is she doing in my home?
Making a mess?
Making all that noise.
I'm trying to find a mate right now.
The worst part is that it got used to it.
It actually got used to my door slamming.
Oh my god.
At one point I was trying my best to slam the door.
I slammed it like 3 times in a row.
And it still kept going.
I was like crap.
It's not phased anymore.
He just thinks it's just nature.
He's like oh it must be like...
It must be like some nature thing.
In my new place that I'm living in.
It's like a little bit of a mess.
I was like...
I'm going crazy with this cicada.
I'm going to sleep in my streaming room for a bit.
Oh no.
That's terrible.
Oh my god.
That sucks.
I'm just like thinking.
How did it get in your walls?
I don't know.
I have no idea actually.
I'm actually not sure how the hell it got in a place.
It's like a pipe or something.
It's really weird.
You know how cicadas only come up after a couple of decades.
You know that right?
Well no.
Not really actually.
You know why?
I've never had a cicada near my home before.
I've never.
That was like my first time ever.
And I was like...
Why is there a cicada in my wall?
I've never heard this before.
Okay so like...
Cicadas are actually...
They live underground.
They lay dormant for a long time.
And then like after like...
Oh yeah.
After like 17 years.
They come out.
And they'll be like...
I don't know if that's like Asia.
I don't know if that's Asian cicadas.
Is this the same as Asian cicadas?
I'm not actually that sure.
But I know like...
In NA it was a problem.
Really?
I don't even know that.
Because like in NA...
Oh I think I heard about it.
Yeah yeah.
So like...
In NA they come out after 17 years.
So like in NA...
They actually have like a...
Like a calendar.
To let people know when the cicadas...
Come out.
And then like...
So at one point...
There was two cicadas...
That were gonna come out...
At the same day.
Like on the same day.
Which was crazy.
Because like it was gonna be a huge problem.
Because there's so many of them.
I saw like some news about that.
People on the news were freaking out.
Yeah yeah.
In NA we have the 17 years ones.
People were like...
Oh no there's gonna be so many cicadas.
It was like an invasion.
It was gonna be an invasion.
It was similar to like the killer bees.
Yeah.
It was similar.
I don't know why but for some reason...
NA has like some fucked up thing with bugs.
Because we also had like the killer bees at one point.
Where there was like an infestation of bees.
Like the killer wasp.
Oh yeah the killer wasp.
There was an infestation of killer wasp.
I'm scared of wasps.
Me too.
I'm freaking scared of wasps as well.
And yeah there was like...
A killer wasp epidemic.
Or something.
And then like...
There was on the news and stuff.
Like oh no the killer wasp are moving to like this area now.
Oh my god be careful everybody.
It was a problem.
So scary.
Yeah.
Yeah it was a problem.
I'm scared.
I'm not usually that scared of bugs.
But like if it's like in large numbers.
Or if it's like...
Okay deadly or something like that.
Like it'll hurt me.
Then I'm pretty scared.
Like okay no.
Oh yeah.
That's why I have immense fear of insects.
I have such a fear.
I just...
I don't care how small they are.
They just...
They look weird.
They look funky too.
It's like where do you put butterflies?
Butterflies.
Have you ever seen a close up picture of a butterfly?
It's hideous.
Aren't they cute?
No.
Look up a close up photo of a butterfly.
Really?
No.
They're fucking disgusting.
Isn't it cute?
What do you mean?
It's pretty cute.
Your definition of cute is...
Now I'm judging your definition.
It's not that.
It's pretty.
What do you mean?
Look at the eyes.
It's so big.
It's so cute.
There's millions of little dots in their eyes.
What?
Okay the only bug I will say is cute is the domesticated moth.
Have you seen...
Moths are pretty cute.
Okay I only think the domesticated moths are cute.
It's because they're also like extra fluffy.
But like I told my chat this.
But domesticated moths are...
We domesticated them so hard.
That like their main purpose is when they come out of their cocoons.
Is to bang, lay eggs and then die five days later.
That's their life span.
Because like they can't fly.
Because we domesticated them.
So like they cannot fly at all.
So like their wings are just decorations.
And then their mouths don't work.
They're just decorations.
They can't eat at all.
That's so sad.
It's like so fucked up.
But that means it can never fly on me.
So like...
True.
I think like insects that can fly is the most fucked up thing ever.
Because like I just don't want them to fly at me.
And like so...
Basically their mouths they can't use it to eat or anything.
It's just like decoration.
So they don't have like...
It doesn't work.
It's like they don't have like...
Well at least they get to get you know...
They get to bang before it.
But the thing is...
I told my chat this.
But like the moths...
Like the male moths don't know...
They don't know how to stop.
So like they'll be like stuck to the female moths.
And you have to like pry them out their cells.
Because like they don't know how to pull out.
So like the owners have to like...
Have to like...
Like pull them out by themselves.
Like the breeders.
And then cause then if the male moths don't...
The female moths can't lay eggs.
So like cause they would be stuck together until they die.
Oh my god!
I learned something today.
Thank you.
Cause like the...
Like people have... like humans have to intervene.
Or they'll like...
They'll be stuck together until they fucking die.
And the female moths won't be able to lay eggs.
So then...
Well...
Wow.
But yeah and then they starve to death because they can't eat.
Aww...
Yeah...
That's pretty sad.
That's their whole purpose.
I think that's like a lot of insects whole purpose.
It's just a...
It's just a bang and then...
I mean like...
I told a story before but like...
There's a species of mice that also does it.
The male mice bang so much that they just get a heart attack and die.
Wait...
How much?
Like... a lot.
To the point where they get a heart attack.
Wait how much do you have to do that to get a heart attack?
I don't know.
I'm confused.
I think this is a research you have to do yourself.
I don't wanna...
I don't wanna have that search history of like...
There's too much cardio.
I learned that in National Geographic.
About the mice.
I think it was like...
I don't remember.
For some reason that memory...
That fact...
The mouse fact is so like...
ingrained in my head.
Why is it so ingrained in your head?
Okay... it's really fucked up.
Because like...
I was like in my grandparents room.
And I was like watching TV.
In my grandparents room.
And I was like watching National Geographic.
And I rarely ever get a chance to be in my grandparents room.
And in like that one moment.
I get to be in my grandparents room.
And I was just by myself in the room.
And I was just watching National Geographic.
And that rat mouse fact.
Just stayed in my head for the longest time.
Because I was like...
One of those rare moments I get to be in my grandparents room.
And it still happened.
It was about the rat...
I don't remember anything...
I don't remember anything else from that show.
I just remember the mouse thing.
Because I was just like...
It was so interesting.
Oh my god.
My mod found the species.
The type of rat.
Really?
I think it is that rat.
Oh yeah.
They found it.
They are like...
The mouse experienced mass mortality after mating.
With mouse survival only observed in the very rare cases.
When they actually found the rat species.
Holy shit.
That's crazy.
Wow.
I never knew that.
I'm learning so much new.
Until they get a heart attack.
I know you are learning Chinese by the way.
I know.
You are like...
Wait.
Here is an animal fact.
In China.
No.
Not in Chinese.
Do you remember that bear that looks like a human?
Wait.
The sun bear?
Oh.
I know.
I've seen it.
I've seen pictures of it.
Yeah.
Do you remember that?
I don't know.
Yeah.
People were like... Is that a person?
I remember when it went viral.
I've seen it.
I was like...
Wait.
That's not a person.
Yeah.
People were like...
And then the zoo had to like...
Release the statement.
Yeah.
The zoo had to release the statement.
I was like... Please stop calling our sun bear a human.
He is a real bear.
They hired...
A person to just be in the outfit.
Yeah.
During the summer.
That person would fucking die.
It's so fucking humid.
Yeah.
But honestly...
It does look like one.
It does.
Okay.
But...
Yeah.
True.
It does look like a human.
It doesn't look like a real bear.
That sun bear has always never looked like a real bear.
I remember I saw the video and I was like...
Holy shit.
It does look like a person.
Yeah.
I actually thought...
I was like... No way that could be a bear.
That's just somebody in a barrel.
Look at his eyes.
He has a lot of skin.
I think this is my favorite picture of a sun bear.
Don't worry guys.
He looks like a fucking NPC.
Doesn't he?
I'm big now.
Give me a second.
Let me resize.
I'm like looking at the...
Even just randomly googling.
It's so weird.
Okay.
Wait.
Let me show my chat.
The sun bear.
I'm looking back at sun bears too.
And I'm like... Oh my god.
Like... Yeah.
I saw this image.
It was definitely this image.
And like I saw this.
I was like... No.
It's a person just waving.
It is.
Here you guys.
Here's a sun bear.
This is a real bear.
It's not a fucking 3D model guys.
It's a real bear.
Look.
You can tell it's a guy too.
It's really goofy.
It's so fucking funny.
I love it.
I love how goofy they are.
They're so fucking...
I don't know.
It just looks like a human.
And when I first saw it.
It was the waving picture.
So I was like...
No.
That can't be real.
Yeah.
It's just a person waving.
A guy and a bear.
Also the mouth.
How it's always open.
It looks like it's just static.
You know?
Why are you scamming us?
It's a person.
They're like...
Please stop saying our bear is a human being.
He's a real bear.
I love...
I love the random...
animal facts.
Especially the pandas.
I love...
Have you seen videos of...
pandas being taken care of?
Actually pandas are so cute.
But they're really stupid though.
I was watching a video.
We have to...
We have to literally take care of them.
Or they'll die out.
We're literally making sure they don't die out.
Because without human intervention...
They cannot take care of themselves.
I'm pretty sure.
I was watching a video.
Someone was like...
That makes them more cute.
Because they can't take care of themselves.
Animals that are a bit stupid...
are pretty cute.
Because like...
I remember...
There was a video I was watching.
Of the zookeepers...
Trying to...
Take care...
It takes a very long time for pandas to...
Um...
Reproduce.
I think they reproduce once a year or something.
Not even once a year.
It's longer.
But you have to force them to.
Because they're never in the mood.
Like...
I remember I was watching a video.
A documentary.
Talking about pandas and the scientists.
And the zookeepers trying to make them...
Because they're endangered.
The problem was that they had to...
Show pandas videos.
Of how other pandas bang.
To encourage them.
To get in the mood.
Hey...
What?
This is how they do it.
It's not.
Yeah...
Yeah... and then...
And then...
If a female panda has twins.
They will...
They cannot process that they have twins.
So they'll be like...
No, I can only have one child.
So what a zookeeper does...
They would...
Because the baby pandas have to...
Still need the mom to...
They still need the mom to...
Take care of them.
So what they do is that they swap...
The baby pandas with each other.
So they'll be like...
Daytime...
Daytime you get your mama.
Nighttime we're swapping.
But then the mama can't understand that.
They just think it's one child.
They just think it's one kid.
And then it's so funny.
Because I was watching a video of how they do the swaps.
And all they do is just give the panda...
Like...
Food.
They'll be like...
Here's food.
And then like...
Just take the child.
And then the mama will be like...
Food.
And then they just grab the child out of the panda's hand.
And then like...
Put another child in her hand.
And she just doesn't notice.
She doesn't care.
She doesn't do this or she doesn't care.
W.
Yeah it's like...
Food.
W.
And like...
You know how they only eat bamboo, right?
But like...
Bamboo gives zero...
Almost zero energy.
So they have to eat...
So much bamboo...
To barely have energy.
Every day.
Because it gives like...
Zero fucking energy for a panda.
And that's why they're mostly like...
Sleeping.
Because they have to save energy.
Dude.
It's actually...
Oh my god.
It's just like...
I feel like we're just making...
Pandas worse.
Like worse as in like...
We're making them lazier.
Yeah.
But they can't...
But the problem is like...
They just can't survive already.
They can't.
Yeah there's nothing we can do.
So there's nothing yet.
We just don't want them to die out.
Because they're so cute.
Like we have to.
We have to.
Dude they're just too cute.
But oh my god.
If we did not intervene.
I feel like...
I don't know.
I don't think they would be existing at this point.
If we didn't intervene.
It's so funny.
Like watching...
Oh my gosh and then...
They're like...
Baby pandas are like incredibly...
They're like incredibly clingy too.
Yeah they like...
There was a video I was watching with Zookeeper.
And there was like three pandas.
Three baby pandas just holding on to her legs.
It's like don't go.
Don't go.
Yeah they're so cute.
Oh my god.
They're so cute.
They are.
But they're so stupid.
It's okay.
Like I was saying.
People just like stupid animals.
Yeah they're just like...
That's what makes them cuter.
Wait.
You gotta keep it Chinese.
Okay stupid.
Shit.
Okay wait.
I know this.
Fuck.
It's in the top of my head.
Is it T-Scene?
No.
T-Scene is crazy.
That's crazy right?
Wait what is it?
What's stupid again?
It's the cute one.
Oh the cute one.
They say they call you like...
like...
Oh yeah yeah.
Yeah.
蠢 蠢 is Cantonese.
Yeah yeah yeah.
It's cute.
But it's a cute way of saying it.
It's not really scolding you or anything.
Like really cursing you.
It's just calling you a little bit stupid.
It's like...
That's why people like to watch me.
Cause I'm cute and stupid.
And you too right?
I'm basically like a panda.
Guys I'll die if you guys don't watch me.
I'm not stupid.
Excuse me?
I literally have...
Yeah I have like...
901 IQ by the way.
In my description.
I'm extremely high IQ.
I'm sorry.
I'm just like...
I'm just like a panda.
Oh my god.
I need human intervention.
I do not feed the panda chat.
Guys I'm so hungry.
Do you wanna eat bamboo?
Guys...
Oh my god.
That's why people like to watch me.
I'm just like a panda.
I'm cute but stupid.
Yeah.
Can't...
Human intervention.
Please intervene to keep me alive.
I like how this was a try to speak Chinese stream.
And then we're here.
I'm here giving like animal facts.
Hey but it's still a theme.
I know.
You gave me like so many animal facts.
Yeah but they're like relevant.
Because like pandas are from China.
And like...
And like that mouse...
The mouse fact I talked about.
Are you trying to like...
You're supposed to speak in Chinese.
Okay but like...
And also that mouse fact I told you guys about.
I learned it when I was like in China.
I learned that fact when I was in China watching it in my grandparents room.
And also...
The silk moths...
The domesticated moths.
They're silk moths.
Which is relevant because like silk is very popular in Asia too.
So like all my facts were very relevant to the topic.
How will you retell a rating in Chinese?
Do you know that this thing is...
very relevant?
Very relevant.
Very relevant to this topic.
Because what I say is...
representative of...
representative of Chinese things.
That's why...
What I say is very relevant to...
What you get to teach me...
Cantonese as well.
Oh yeah.
I think I know some curse words.
Thanks to like people saying it.
Yeah.
Nooooooo!
That's pervert.
Why do you know pervert?
I only know...
I only know a few curse words.
Who taught you pervert?
My chat.
Wait, are they calling you...
They called you ham-sop?
No!
They're like teaching me words.
And they're like, hey you should learn this one.
You should learn this.
Wait, do you know pervert in Chinese?
Wait, not in...
What is it?
It sounds similar to the Japanese word.
Wait, what is it?
Hentai?
Yeah, it sounds similar to that.
Wait, how do you say it?
What I know is...
Oh, bientai.
Wait, that's pervert?
Yeah.
So I can be like, you're a pervert.
Can you say that?
Yeah.
Yeah, you can.
But I'm not a pervert.
But you can.
I can say it though.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's...
When I was learning it, I was like...
Yeah, it sounds exactly like the Japanese one.
Yay!
So easy.
Bientai has a negative connotation.
Well, it's pervert.
Pervert has a negative connotation in general.
Isn't that pervert?
There's no way you could make pervert a positive connotation, guys.
Pervert is positive?
How can pervert be a positive connotation?
It's negative in general.
Yeah.
Wait, I'm trying to...
Is there a way?
No way.
No.
You can't be a good pervert.
There's no way you can be a good pervert.
What do you mean?
Oh my god.
You can say it in like a cute way, I guess.
Bientai.
Wow, you're a pervert.
I mean, that's what...
Don't you know, they play koi?
Oh, true, true.
You know how they are, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Even in Japanese, it's like a kind of tsundere type.
Like, huh?
Bientai?
You know, like...
Like that, you know?
You know what I mean?
Why did you say brother?
Yeah, it's looking the same.
No, it's like that.
My sister can't be that cute.
No!
Actually, when I was learning it, that confused me a lot.
Because in Chinese, they always say like 哥哥 and 姐姐 for everything.
Everybody calls them 哥哥 and 姐姐.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Oh, but recently, there's another one, you know.
They like to say 兄弟.
兄弟?
What does that mean?
兄弟 is like bro.
兄弟你好小.
Yeah.
Like, you smell so good, bro.
Bro, what?
Yeah!
Wait, how do you use that in a context?
What's the context?
The context is he smells good.
Why would you use that?
Like, um...
I guess...
When you're trying to...
When you're trying to joke with somebody, I guess?
Yeah.
Yeah!
Wait, there's like a picture for it too.
Bro, you smell good when you're trying to...
Wait, how do you say it again?
Yeah, 兄弟.
兄弟你好小.
It's a popular meme now.
Wait, really?
Bro, you smell good.
At least in the Chinese...
Yeah, in the Chinese community, I don't know why they just like... and then they sniff.
And then they just...
They're like, you smell good.
兄弟 No, it's not 兄弟.
兄弟 What's the last...
How do you say the last part?
兄弟你好小 兄弟你好小 兄弟你好小 兄弟你好小 兄弟你好小 兄弟你好小 兄弟你好小 兄弟你好小
兄弟你好小 Bro, you smell good, bro.
X-I-A-N-G
你好小 is like, okay...
That's a bit too much.
兄弟你好小 Actually, there's... I don't know why, but there's like a lot of like...
like weird... like those kind of jokes.
You know, that they like to just randomly say.
Not really even in a perverted way.
It's just they like to joke around like that.
Yeah.
I think... yeah, then there's another one.
基建 基建 基建, you know 基建.
基建 is like fencing.
Fencing?
What does that mean?
Just try and think of it in like a weird way.
In a weird way?
What do you mean by weird?
Fencing with something.
Wait...
Why do you know that word?
Because that's the thing they teach me.
Why?
They teach...
What's the context?
Yeah.
It's just fencing.
That's the context.
You know?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
It's like sword fighting.
It's also not even in a perverted...
Like nobody really regards it as like a perverted meaning.
It's just like a joke to them.
You know what I mean?
Oh, it's just like bro you want to fence?
Like a joke type, you know?
It's purely joking.
Girls say it too.
Oh yeah.
It's purely joking.
Yeah.
It's like 1v1 me bro.
I feel like it's really bad when you translate it.
But like...
It's really funny just to hear it as like a joke.
Oh that's funny.
Wait that's so funny.
Wait wait wait.
How do you pronounce it again?
It's literally fencing.
Xi jian?
J-I-J-I-J-I-A-N.
Yeah.
Xi jian.
Bro.
Bro, Xi jian.
Xi jian wo.
Wait!
Okay, nobody says it like that.
Wait, fence me bro.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Fence me bro.
Did no one just say fencing?
No bro.
I don't think they add a wall.
You know, like me.
Fence me.
It's 1v1 me bro.
Oh I can't.
I'm trying to say 1v1 me bro.
1v1.
Actually do you know 1v1 in like Chinese?
No no, how do you say 1v1?
It's just ee dai ee.
It's just like one hit one.
Oh ee dai ee.
Hahaha.
Yeah.
I can't believe it.
I made it worse.
Yeah you did make it worse actually.
I was thinking like.
Nooooo.
You know what's the worst part?
Like that meme.
Like the xiong di ni hao xiang.
That one is like they usually use it with like chikawa.
Do you know chikawa?
No what is that?
It's a very cute Japanese animation.
It like got super popular.
Basically in their community.
And like they.
I don't know why some genius just put like the text on top of like a really cute character.
Show me show me.
And it's just so sad.
Wait I'll show you a picture.
It's so sad.
Like uh.
I'll copy this.
Okay.
Sending it.
Ah.
So cute.
Oh wait I know.
I know that.
I never knew like the name of it.
But I always see it.
It's so popular too.
Chikawa.
Yeah it's very cute.
If you've never watched chikawa.
It's very.
I've never watched chikawa.
I've seen it everywhere.
It's so popular now.
It's like the new hamtaro.
It's like the modern day hamtaro.
It's very cute.
Yeah.
Back in our day.
Or back.
I don't know about Hiro's day.
But back in my day.
It's very short.
We had hamtaro.
I know hamtaro.
Like a little bit.
I didn't watch it.
You never watched hamtaro?
I remember there's like toys.
Yeah but I remember like.
They had like toys of them.
And I was like.
When I was a kid.
I remember when you buy like.
I think McDonald's maybe.
Like some drinks.
They'll give you toys right?
And like.
I remember there's like hamtaro toys.
And I was like.
What is this?
It's cute.
Could you say that to hamtaro?
Hamtaro walked so chikawa can run.
Hamtaro started the cute rodent fad.
When was hamtaro?
Hamtaro was so fucking old.
Like hamtaro if he was a real hamster.
Would be dead right now.
Oh wait.
I mean.
Okay.
It's true.
He's old.
He must be really old.
No.
It's like.
Apparently somebody said 90s.
Oh my god.
Is hamtaro that old?
Okay but it's like 90s in Japan.
So like by the time it came to NA.
Like by the time it came to NA.
It was like a lot older.
Yes.
I am very sure it takes years to get.
It takes years to get shows to be like dubbed in English.
Okay.
I only know the English opening.
Apparently like Japanese opening for hamtaro is like really popular.
But I only know the English one.
English opening?
Yeah the English opening.
Oh I'm big again.
The English opening for hamtaro.
Wait let me see if I can find it.
I didn't even know there is like English opening.
English opening.
Yeah back then in NA.
A lot of the shows.
Like you know how Sailor Moon like.
Bum ba da da dum bum bum.
Like the.
The opening for Sailor Moon got like.
Dubbed into English as well.
Like a lot of the openings.
Back then would get like dubbed into English openings.
Cause they are like.
NA people are so stupid.
We need to dub everything.
For them.
Or they won't watch it.
They won't watch it.
If the openings are not in English.
I honestly.
I still watch anime.
And I watch sub.
I don't watch dub at all.
Yeah but like when you are growing up.
Like when you are growing up.
It's all we had.
So like all the openings were.
And like the openings didn't even like make sense sometimes.
Like are like different from the original.
Like the opening was like.
The original opening.
So like have you ever heard of the Digimon opening in English?
Wait what?
No.
Wait okay.
Cause like you know Digimon opening in Japan is butterfly right?
Yeah I like.
Yeah you like.
Yeah butterfly.
I grew up with the English Digimon opening.
What?
I never heard of butterfly before.
Until like.
Really?
It was only until like.
I think like in high school.
When I heard of the.
When I heard of butterfly for the first time.
I was like what's this?
What the hell?
It's totally different.
Digimon.
Digital Monsters.
Digital Monsters Champion.
What is Digimon?
What is this?
Digital.
This cut.
This is the only one we had.
No.
I have never heard of the Digimon.
English opening.
No.
It was all we had.
Okay.
It was pretty catchy.
It was pretty good back then.
This is so interesting.
I've never heard of Digimon opening.
I've never seen this before.
I'm like just watching it.
I'm like what the hell is this?
What is this?
It's just really different.
It's like so different.
And then we would have like.
I mean you know like the classic ones.
The one with like.
Oh wait do you know Yu-Gi-Oh?
Have you ever watched Yu-Gi-Oh?
Like the Japanese opening of Yu-Gi-Oh?
I have.
Okay I'll show you Yu-Gi-Oh ones.
Wait there's Yu-Gi-Oh too?
Yeah yeah yeah.
Yu-Gi-Oh opening English.
Well it is like.
Well there was no singing really.
They're just like.
We got a d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-door.
It's time to.
D-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-dr.
D-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d- Nooo.
It's always funny when people.
Cause like I never heard of Butterfly.
Until highschool cause like.
Like that The Digimon movies.
Like that Digimon movies were like.
Uh becoming a thing.
And people were like Digimon movies.
And then.
I love Digimon.
I know that Digimon was like super popular.
Super popular.
Oh, they're figures!
Yeah, it's really big.
It's like, almost like...
compared with the Japan level, you know?
Yeah.
The cons, the conventions...
That is so true.
Yeah, they have like...
whole anime dedicated streets.
Yeah, yeah.
There's like... I don't remember like...
I don't remember where I was...
but I remember going to the street...
and it was like, you know, like tailors and stuff...
that's specifically there to make cosplay.
Like...
Have you ever been to the streets where...
It's just a cosplay street.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And there's like all these aunties...
Everybody would come out with cosplays.
Yeah, all these aunties and grannies there...
that would make like cosplay items.
And I was like... It was so cute!
Dude, cause like...
It's like all these aunties and grannies...
they would have like these books and be like...
What kind of cosplay do you want us to make you?
And then they would be like making cosplays...
and stuff for like...
cosplayers too.
It's so cute.
Yeah, all the owners are like...
It's all like older people.
It's really cute.
It's really, really cute.
It's so cute, yeah.
And it's so good quality too.
I did go.
Like Shanghai, I recently landed in March, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Shanghai is extremely like...
Anime culture is extremely big there.
Yeah.
There's like collaboration cafes...
There's like a whole mall...
which is like...
Just for otaku!
There's like Bidi Bidi merch as well.
There's like Bidi Bidi anime merch.
Wait, did you spot your own merch?
I saw my Nendo.
Oh, it's so cute!
That's really cute though.
You must be like...
That's me!
But you can't see it cause you want to dox yourself.
So you're like...
Yeah, I went with my other friend.
My other Vtuber friend.
And we were like...
Can't see anything.
He took pictures of everybody that I knew by the way.
He was like...
Okay, I know this guy.
Hey!
Take a picture.
He was like... I see you!
That's so cool though.
It's really interesting.
Yeah, that's so cool.
Oh my god.
There's like Bocchi.
I remember when there was like Bocchi the Rock.
Do you know Bocchi the Rock?
Yeah, I know Bocchi the Rock.
I didn't watch it but I know it's super mainstream.
It's very nice!
Actually I like Bocchi.
Bocchi was pretty nice.
I only know it because of the meme.
The Face.
Like, when she starts dying and then like the face she makes.
That's the only thing I know about Bocchi the Rock.
Bocchi the Rock.
Like the meme faces she makes.
The music is really nice!
I like the music a lot.
I haven't seen the show cause it's based off like a rock band.
It would be sad if it was like the rock band anime show and then the music sucks.
It's all about the music.
Currently, everyone is like Raging over Bochy.
And then there is My Go now, I think.
What?
What's that?
It's M-Y-G-O.
I think it's Bang Dream.
Do you know Bang Dream?
No.
It's not normie enough for me.
It's not mainstream so I don't know.
Yeah.
So everyone loves it over in the Chinese community.
They love that too.
It's the music too, right?
The music is just really really good.
Yeah.
Music is like a big thing.
Oh, it's a rhythm game?
Bang Dream?
I have figures of Bang Dream, the girls.
Oh, I thought it was like an anime.
Because it's like...
There is an anime.
But it's like...
Yeah?
Yeah.
It's like...
There's a rhythm game.
There's an anime.
And the anime just came out not too long ago.
Like...
Are those like the...
Like those rhythm games where you have to wear gloves and stuff to play it?
It's like the circle, you know?
Yeah.
And then you just like...
The girl.
Then the girl.
You can call it the cards, I think.
Yeah.
Like...
Oh my gosh.
It's so hardcore.
When I see people play rhythm games, people like...
I remember like...
Have you tried?
No.
I'm so bad at rhythm.
I have zero rhythm.
But like...
People go so hard on rhythm games.
It's actually crazy.
Because it's actually crazy impressive too.
Because I remember like seeing like some...
I think like...
Like I think...
Like when I was in Asia.
Like I just see like this guy who just got out of work.
You can tell that he just got out of work.
And he has like those professional gloves on for the rhythm games.
Yeah.
And then he would like put his suitcase down.
And like...
And like scrunch up his sleeves and stuff.
Put the gloves on and go...
Yeah.
I know.
I was like...
Like...
Yeah.
My, my.
Right?
Yeah.
I had a friend that had gloves before.
Like I was just randomly going with her like just to hang out together.
Yeah.
And like we just passed by the arcade actually.
And she was like, hey, can we stop by the arcade for a while?
And I was like, okay, no problem.
I like games.
So I was like...
I went in.
I didn't buy anything.
I didn't play anything.
I just watched her go crazy.
She took out...
She had like a bag and she just took out like these white gloves and I was like, oh, we have gloves?
And she had like this big bottle of water as well.
Just like ready there.
And she's like going crazy.
I was like, what the heck?
So it's like you have to reduce the friction or you'll screw your combo.
Oh my God.
That's so hardcore.
It's like when like FPS gamers have to buy like a mouse pad on the PC.
And they have to put it on top of their mouse pad because the friction will ruin them.
It's just like that.
I was so surprised because she played like...
I remember like at the time I think she was playing osu!
You know osu!
Yeah.
She played osu!
As well.
She was like some top player and I was like, oh God.
She's this girl.
Yeah.
She just played like rhythm games only I think.
Like she only played rhythm games.
That's so cool though.
So she was like...
Yeah.
It was like my first time because I don't...
I play a little bit but I don't really, you know, go at it.
I don't play it that much so I was just like watching her the entire time.
I think it's also just like it's like super impressive because it's like the dedication to and how fast they go as well.
Like the...
Like how fast your hands go.
They're like...
I can't see.
Like my eyes are hurting.
Like I'm looking around and it's empty.
It's just like oh my God.
How do you know what to hit?
I think like...
But like arcades are like so popular in LN Asia.
Arcades are still very popular.
Like fucking NA.
It's like it dies.
Like people are just...
People would just be like why do I have to play... go play at an arcade when I can just play at home, you know?
They'll be like oh I have...
I have PC.
I have my consoles.
Why do I need to go to arcades?
Yeah, a lot of arcades in NA have died out but like I know like...
Because arcades in NA is like a children thing.
Like we see it as like for kids.
The games aren't different.
Like...
Like are pretty different maybe.
Well, there's like a lot of kids games as well but like even if they have like some games that are made for adults like rhythm games and stuff like that.
It's just not popular in NA.
But like in Asia, it's like it's mostly for adults with like a lot of like arcade machines and like the rhythm games and stuff like that.
And I think it's also like UFO catchers and stuff.
Yeah.
I like UFO catchers.
I love UFO catchers too.
But like...
I'm always so sad because I'm like crap.
I know I should just buy the item but I can't resist.
I just want to try.
I just want to try a few times and then I fail and I'm like okay maybe I'll try a few more times.
I feel like I failed.
And then you'd be like please...
And then you ask somebody like please can you help me.
Ask those attendants like can you make it easier?
Like oh yeah.
And also like in NA like we have to have prizes in NA.
Like you know like tickets and stuff.
So like if you do well in arcades like you get tickets to exchange it for like prizes.
But like I know like in Asia arcades you just play the game.
Like there's no like actual prizes.
It's like the prize is the experience of gaming.
I think a long time ago there may have been.
Yeah but it got like...
It's just different now.
Yeah.
It died out.
The prize system.
But yeah because like there's just like actual good arcade games and stuff.
Yeah.
It's just like you go there and play the actual games and have fun.
Yeah it's just the experience.
I miss arcades.
And there's like...
And then there's like some areas where you have to be like...
You have to be like 18 or older to like go in.
Wait really?
Yeah.
I remember this because I remember I was like in the...
The only reason I remember this is because I think I was like in...
I think I was like in like Hong Kong airport.
And then like there was a section there where you can like...
There was like a section where you can like...
There was like a section like the bottom like the arcades was like you have to be 18 to go to the arcade.
Because we have some games that are for adults only.
And I was like...
And I would be like...
I was like dad I want to go to the arcade.
And then my dad was like no you're not 18.
You can't...
You can't go inside.
And I would be like but there's games inside.
Really?
Yeah.
Because there's like...
I think it's like because like some of the machines it's like...
I think it's like it's sort of like pachinko.
You know like pachinko.
Oh pachinko.
But then they will have like...
I'm not a fan of pachinko.
It's just I think yeah I think...
I think that's why they're like because there's pachinko.
There's like pachinko machines.
So they're like you had no children at all.
But I don't know if it was pachinko.
I just remembered like they wouldn't let me in.
Because they're like she's not 18 so she can't go in.
And I'm like but there's arcade machines.
I see some arcade machines in there.
But you know Japan has like those large pachinko machines.
Oh yeah yeah I know.
It's like all just pachinko.
It's like so popular.
It's crazy.
And then they would have like...
It's like actually really noisy though.
Yeah and they have like crossovers with like different animes and stuff too.
I know there was like a Madoka pachinko machine.
That was super popular.
I know like when I was growing up.
There was like there's like this like children's arcades.
Because there was one was like oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh I think like people who live in Hong Kong will remember this like arcade.
I think it was like USA Jumping Gym.
I think it was like a popular arcade chain.
I think that was what it's called.
Maybe it's not.
Jumping Gym.
I don't know maybe I'm butchering the name.
It was like a super popular like arcade like arcade place.
Wait let me see.
Maybe I'm butchering.
It's not even called that.
No it is.
It's called Jumping Gym USA.
Yeah.
Jumping Gym USA.
Yeah it was like a super popular.
It was like a super popular like kids arcade area.
Like where there's like kids.
Where there's like prizes and stuff too.
Yes the rainbow one!
Okay and then it was so funny because there would be like those coin pusher games.
It'll be like you know like the ones where you put a coin in.
And it pushes out tokens and stuff.
And then because like so I think it's because like there's like no you know there's no like gambling places and stuff like that.
And so like all the grannies, all the grandparents and like would just be sitting at the coin pushers.
Because it's like for them it was like.
They're away of like a casino.
Like with the coin pusher.
And I was like...
And then I would like... I would go.
I would be like...
Yay!
USA Jumping Gym!
I can't wait!
I can't wait to play!
Because you can win prizes.
And there was like a lot of fun arcade games.
I was really... I was a little kid.
And then all the coin pushers...
Kids and parents can just be there.
Yeah, and then all the coin pushers were occupied by the grandparents.
See all these... the grandparents just be at the coin pushers.
Just with like a huge bag of tickets.
Because it's tickets.
So they'll have like a huge plastic bag filling up the tickets and stuff.
And then they'll have like a collection of coins.
Just like doing the coin pusher.
I'll just be like...
I want to play the coin pusher too.
Yeah, as a kid you don't really know.
You just want to play everything.
I'd be like...
I want to play too.
Yeah.
It was just so interesting.
Like I would remember every time...
Because there were multiple.
There were multiple of this like...
The Jumping Gym USA.
And then I would always see like...
Like so many grandparents just always at the coin pushers every time.
Because we had kids and grandparents.
I think you're still at the coin pusher.
Like...
On me.
Yeah, I think...
Jesus.
Like Pachinko and coin pushers are like...
Still...
Really popular.
It is really popular.
Yeah.
Like I remember like...
My grandma won me.
Like won my family a fucking...
Oh is it?
A rice cooker from...
Yeah!
Rice cooker!
The prizes...
Because like the prizes there...
Like when they do have prizes...
They're like actual like good prizes.
So there'll be like vacuum cleaners.
Because it like encourages people.
Because they're like...
Oh my god.
We can actually get like good stuff.
Like so there'll be like vacuum cleaners.
Cooking appliances.
Like rice cookers and stuff like that.
It'll be like...
It's like there's like...
Rice cooker.
Kids toys.
Like there's be like toys for kids.
And then there'll be like...
Like appliances.
Wait.
I'll tell you like a story.
Like I...
Like the...
Have you ever won something before?
Like just randomly?
Like I won...
I think the best item I won when I was like a kid.
Was like a phone.
I actually won a phone.
Oh really?
But...
You know what?
I was so young.
I was like 8 or 9.
Yeah.
And like my parents were like...
Oh you don't need that phone.
You don't want...
Dad will use it.
Like my dad will use it for now.
And like...
My phone and like my dad just took it and used it instead.
I was like oh...
How did you won the phone?
I just like...
I forgot how it was like a lottery or something.
And like...
They're calling people's names.
And it's calling numbers I think.
And then like...
My number was like...
You got a phone.
And I was so happy.
I was like oh my god.
I won a phone.
Yeah you did.
And I gave it to my parents and like...
You're too young.
I was like our phone now.
Your phone?
No our phone.
Yeah.
I was like so sad.
I was like...
But phone.
Well I guess I didn't get my phone.
No.
No phone.
I remember they gave me something else.
They gave me their gift.
I remember their gift was like some wallet or something.
Not as expensive as a phone.
It was like a tiny one.
It was very tiny.
I was like oh.
Nice.
It's okay.
At least you get to hold it for a cup for a little bit.
Yeah.
I was like yeah.
You need to feel the sense of winning a phone.
Yeah I had the box in my hand.
Yeah yeah.
You're like at least I have that box.
No I put it down actually.
Like I went to sleep.
And then like I put it down.
I put it on the table.
And like the next day it was gone.
I was like where did it go?
Oh damn.
It's like well.
One day with a phone.
Yeah.
I was like damn.
Damn.
Well oop.
You got the experience.
At least you got the experience.
You know it's all about the experience.
Yeah.
I was kind of okay.
I was like okay.
Because I was like rationalizing.
Rationalizing.
With myself.
I was like okay maybe I am too young to wear a phone.
Maybe my parents are right.
You know what?
It's okay.
They can use it.
How old were you when you had your first phone?
I don't remember.
Damn.
I remember it was like my dad's phone that he gave me.
Oh yeah.
It was like their second hand phone.
Yeah like I think like I was like middle school when I had my first phone.
I think.
Because I was like all my friends had phones.
Like cell phones.
Oh like my first phone was the...
I don't know if you remember Motorola?
Oh yeah.
You remember that phone?
I do.
And then it was like Motorola.
It sings that funky song.
I think I saw some like adults using it.
That's why it's old.
Yeah it was like a hand-me-down.
It was a hand-me-down.
Yeah.
I remember I got a phone from my parents and then I loved that phone because it would sing the song was so funny.
I was like somebody call me so I can listen to the song.
Hello Moto.
Yes!
I was like...
It's true.
It would be like...
Hello Moto.
It was so good.
I was like I hope somebody calls me so I can listen to that song.
I remember I used to like borrow...
I like like take my dad's phone out because like back then I think there's like no games on phones.
Right?
Those were really old phones.
And like I was like a little kid.
Yeah!
Snake!
I will only play snake.
And there's like those like shooting ones.
The one like you control like the plane and shoot stuff all the time.
Yeah.
Just like those two games and just play it over and over.
Guys we're not old.
Okay guys those were just hand-me-downs guys.
We're not old.
It was just hand-me-downs.
Yeah.
I was just excited to get a phone I think in the first one I ever had.
I was so excited.
I was like...
Oh my god I got my own phone.
Guys give me your numbers.
I have a phone now guys.
Yeah and like the first time I had to memorize your own number.
Oh true.
True.
Oh yeah I need to like memorize my own number now.
Then people ask like what's your number?
And I'm like...
Oh.
I don't remember.
Let me look at my own contacts.
Oh my god.
I love how this is...
This is how we devolved that I tried.
Look we tried okay.
We tried to speak Chinese.
We tried.
There's some Chinese.
Yeah yeah.
Look we made it up by like talking about like our like experiences like living in China.
Well my experiences living in China.
Yeah.
Like I guess I'll...
You know what I'll tell you one Chinese thing now like I guess just to you know make it seem like we're dry.
Yeah yeah yeah.
You have to make it relevant.
Like there is like a meme.
I don't know how like sensitive like just like people are in like and like Western culture and all that.
Yeah.
You know games with like for example Apex or something if there's like cheaters or something like for example professionals like caught cheating or something that is like a big thing is like hey oh god no.
Yeah hacking is really bad.
Yeah like okay.
No why why did you go hacking or something.
Yeah.
Like like there's like a lot of like memes of that in like Chinese the Chinese community for like those kind of people.
There's like a really funny one.
Okay.
No there's no it's like all funny by the way.
It's like totally like it just devolves into like okay okay they just like of course it's like a bit bad but like most of it is just like laughing at the person.
Yeah.
All the time.
And it's mostly because like there's like a guy who was like he was like if you're if you're like bad at something like bad at the game.
Yeah.
Just practice more he said he was saying he was like but he was hacking by the way.
So yeah.
Yeah.
So he was he was like a professional in some game or something he was like.
And he was just like oh just just practice more but he was a hacker.
Yeah.
And like the other one is like it's like you can't like take losing don't play.
Like.
Oh.
Yeah.
You're a hacker.
It's really famous actually and it was because he was doing some weird hand gestures and stuff and he looked like a crap by the way.
He knew but practice so it's basically like get good.
Yeah.
It was because like I think he was like playing competition or something and like in the first half he was like getting beaten really badly and like in the second half.
He was killing everybody so everyone was like wait.
Wait a minute that's a hacker.
And he was like that he was like.
Chai!
Jiu gu lian!
Yeah.
It's like it was like some whole big statement it was really funny.
That's so funny.
It is.
Yeah.
I was just like get good.
And there's another one like I think not that old as well like maybe late last year.
Yeah.
Late last year as well which became really big because it was actually a Vtuber by the way that did it.
It was like a tournament for Valorant.
Wait I heard about that.
Did you hear?
Yeah it got it was like people overseas talked about it too.
It was so bad.
It became a meme though because it was really funny.
Everybody started like streaming with like a box on your screen.
Like a little box.
Like a box because it was like the hack she was using.
So yeah it was like.
What is this square?
It's the Clara.
Okay because like people okay the reason why like people overseas knew about it is because we had a similar instance with like Clara.
So like it's a I don't know have you heard about the Clara meme?
Clara?
Okay.
So like the reason why we knew about it is because like in NA.
In NA.
We had a similar experience with like but like it wasn't tournament or anything.
But it was like this girl that was like she's playing CSGO.
And then and then basically it's it's so similar.
It's so similar but basically she like she accidentally did like click something that showed her her walling and stuff.
And then people on her stream were like what the she's hacking.
And then she was like she noticed and then she was like oh my god it's Clara.
Clara installed.
Clara was on my PC.
And installed hacks onto my PC.
Clara!
What did you do Clara?
But obviously people were like who the fuck is Clara?
So she tried to like blame this fucking made up girl named Clara that...
Yeah.
It was like similar issues like I think because of that like people just put a box on your screen the whole time.
And she was like oh what is this box?
What?
What is this box?
Oh it can't move.
Why is it moving with the people?
I think she said it was like because of her setting or like she was doing some preset.
It was like a visual setting.
Like a preset?
Yeah yeah yeah it was like a preset.
And then I was like...
Um yeah.
No.
Preset.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
That's actually people who I don't understand why would you hack though.
I think it's better to just admit that.
Yeah just be bad.
Just leave.
Just end it.
Like go.
Just leave.
I think if you defend yourself.
You can't defend yourself if you like cheat.
You can't defend yourself.
Yeah you can't.
You'll be known as a hacker.
Yeah.
Probably.
So most like hacker like those like big streamers or like people who are Vtuber who you know who just like hack it just becomes memes.
Yeah yeah.
It is.
Oh like destroyer.
It just turns funny.
You remember like you saw the Apex hack?
Destroyer?
I remember that was happening in tournament.
Oh in the tournament?
Yeah yeah.
And then the guy.
I saw that.
Yeah I was watching it live.
It was actually crazy how that guy.
Yeah that guy like hacked like Hal.
I think the funniest part was when you know like Jen Burning got hacked and then he like instantly left the game.
And then when Hal.
I don't know if you saw it but when Hal got hacked.
I was watching.
Yeah yeah.
Hal got hacked.
He said I'm hacked.
And then he shot.
He kept shooting.
He's like.
What if I don't shoot guys?
And then he kept shooting.
It was really funny you know.
It was so funny.
He's like guys I'll just don't shoot.
And then killed two people.
It was funny you know.
But it's just the fact that like the guy who like hacked was just there to be like.
It's crazy though.
The guy that hacked.
Like did you read more about it?
Like he just wanted to like.
Like be public about it to like the Apex devs and was like.
Hey guys like you guys need to fix this.
So he's like.
Really?
Yeah.
I didn't really know.
I just heard about like.
I just saw the video basically.
He did it for like.
The competition.
Publicity.
Because he only did it for attention.
Like he because he's done it before.
He's like hacked people.
He's only hacked pro players to like reveal like security issues.
And he was like advertising.
Yeah.
He was like.
Oh here's some security issues.
And like anyway I did that.
And it was just for publicity.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Yeah it's about sending a message.
Yeah.
Well.
There's a lot of things that needs to be fixed.
So thank god.
True.
Oh my god.
I like Apex.
I love Apex too.
Yeah.
But yeah.
You know sometimes.
Sometimes it needs to be fixed.
Oh 100%.
There's like.
Oh my gosh.
I got like.
I told my chat this.
But like.
Like I get like sneak peeks for like what's gonna happen for like next seasons and stuff.
But like it's so hard to keep the things secret.
Because I actually.
One.
I almost leaked out the solos mode.
Like one month before it came out.
I almost leaked it out on stream.
Because like.
Um.
I was in a tournament.
I was in an Apex tournament.
And then we were joking about like.
Um.
Oh man.
Like soon you can 1v1 people soon.
And then I was like.
I was almost like.
Oh yeah.
Solos.
Uh.
Haha.
It was like.
Oh wait.
I can't say that.
I can't talk about solos modes coming back.
I can't say it.
Oh is it like you're just chatting.
And then like you're.
You're not thinking.
Yeah.
You're not.
I'm not thinking.
Because I knew.
Like I was like.
Oh yeah.
Solos mode.
Because I knew about the solos mode that's coming out.
And then like.
Like when you think about it.
And your mouth just opens.
Yeah.
And I'll just be like.
Not really.
Solo.
Be funny.
Haha.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
I'm also scared.
Like if I knew something.
I think it'll be really hard to keep it to myself.
I just have to not think about it.
I'll just say.
The stuff I know for next season.
Wow.
God.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'll cover your voice in life.
In case you say anything.
In next season 22.
There's going to be.
Ahhhh.
Crazy.
Scary.
That's so scary.
Oh god.
It's okay.
I didn't leak anything though.
I didn't leak anything.
It just almost slipped out.
Because like.
It was just.
The solo mode.
The solo mode thing.
Was like.
It was just right there.
I almost forgot it never existed.
Yeah I get it.
So I was like.
Did you get to play Alter?
Like new?
Like Apex just updated right?
Yeah.
I got to play Alter.
I think Alter is a team.
A team character.
She's so bad at solos mode.
I hate playing her in solos.
She has no mobility.
She has no mobility other than the portal.
So.
Yeah.
I was playing her yesterday.
I played her for a while.
And then I stopped.
And now.
And then everyone was asking.
Hey.
Why aren't you playing the new hero?
I was like.
I don't want to play her anymore.
I'm done.
You're just like.
I'm done playing with you.
I went back.
I went back to Wraith.
I was like.
Okay.
I think she's really good for team fights.
Apparently she's really good for rank and stuff.
Because.
If you're a very aggressive team.
She's really good.
Because you can like.
Get to places and do team fights.
She's basically.
Like.
You know like the Octane rev jump pad thing.
I like her.
Yeah.
I do like her very much.
It's just like.
I was like playing her every single time.
Yeah.
I was like.
I'm done.
I gotta change it up.
Perfect.
I have like.
Do you know.
I have like a problem with Valkyrie actually.
Like.
I played her.
I think in the first season.
I got master.
Like solo master.
Yeah.
I used Valkyrie to play.
Because at the time.
I think it was like.
I forgot which season it was.
But like.
Everybody like.
Playing solo was like hell.
Because everybody just kept like.
Dying immediately.
Like going and just dying.
So you just play Valk and just fly away.
Yeah.
I would just.
I would just fly away.
And I'm like bye.
I'm going right now.
Because I played her so much.
I got like sick of her.
Yeah.
And I haven't played her until today.
And it's been like two years.
It's true.
Like you just get tired of playing the same character.
You just want some variety.
To.
Yeah.
Say that in Chinese.
Because it's a.
Chinese.
Yeah.
Say that in Chinese.
Say what in Chinese?
Say that.
Talk about Valk in Chinese.
Wait.
Do you know her name in Chinese?
What is her.
Her official name is Wajiri.
It's just Valkyrie.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wajiri.
And what do you.
What's the nickname?
But her.
But.
But I call her.
Just.
Just flying lady.
Flying lady.
Fei Niren.
Yeah.
I was going to say.
Fei Niren.
Yeah.
Learning to translate to flying.
It's just.
Flying lady.
I just call her flying lady.
Yeah.
What's the Chinese name for Apex Legends again?
No.
Wait.
We.
Actually.
People don't really call it.
Like.
Do you know what they call it?
What do you call it?
Usually.
Usually what I call it.
And what.
What I've seen people call it.
Is just.
Hai.
Hai?
Yeah.
Hai or hai?
Hai.
Hai?
It's just.
Like.
Hai.
Hai?
Like.
Wait.
What does.
Why?
Why hi?
Hai.
Hai is.
It's like.
Uh.
I forgot why it's.
Hai.
It's like.
Da pai.
You know.
It's like.
Uh.
I forgot.
Wait.
This thing is like.
I really don't remember.
But like.
I'll type it for you.
The actual word.
This.
Hai.
They call it A as well.
Just A.
Just the letter A.
Oh.
Ha ha ha.
A.
This is cute.
Ha ha ha.
Hai.
I think it's just a name.
Apex.
A-pai.
Oh.
That.
I don't know if it says A-pai.
And it's just like shorter.
Like.
I like.
Playing.
Pai.
Is that what they say?
Ha ha.
Do you want to play Pai?
Yeah.
Play Pai.
Ha ha ha.
Yeah.
Do you want to play Pai?
Just play Pai.
It's also like playing cards.
I think or something like that.
Oh yeah.
Like Pai Pai.
Yeah.
So.
Like.
They just call it like.
A-pai.
It's just also A-pai.
Oh.
Yeah.
I see.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
Look I'm learning.
Guys.
See.
We're learning.
I'm learning Chinese.
And I'm trying to speak Chinese.
And I said that in English.
Ha ha ha ha.
You.
Look.
Wait.
Everyone.
Look.
I'm speaking Cantonese now.
But.
But I'm speaking.
I'm speaking.
Ha ha ha.
I can speak Chinese.
You don't.
You don't newbie.
Yeah.
Your Chinese is very newbie.
My Chinese is noobie.
Newbie.
It's like noobie.
It's like noob.
Right?
It's like noob?
No.
Oh wait.
Where is it?
I thought you called me a noobie.
No.
You called me a noob.
Wait.
What did you say?
Newbie.
Newbie is kind of like...
Okay.
The translation is bad.
But the meaning is good.
You know what I mean?
Oh.
Okay.
Like...
Um.
New...
It's like cow...
Anyway.
It's a private part of the cow.
Okay.
Just listen.
What?
Newbie.
New...
Yeah.
Wait.
Why did you call me a cow?
What?
It's either the other or it's the other.
It's the other?
Like the milking?
I think it's the other.
I think it's that.
Or it's the other one which I'm not gonna say.
Oh wait.
Why did you call my Chinese that?
No.
It means it's good in Chinese.
It's good?
Newbie means it's like amazing.
Oh so you're saying my ch...
I know.
My Chinese...
My Chinese is noob.
Newbie.
Yeah.
Are you like gaslighting me?
Are you?
No it's true!
It's true!
Wait it's actually true.
Okay.
I had to be sure because I'm like...
They like to say newbie.
I actually have no idea why.
This is like something I'm taught as well.
And I'm like wait why do you guys like to say newbie?
I don't even know why.
But like...
But like it does mean it's...
You're like it's great.
Something is great.
So you can say like...
Oh.
Like...
You're Chinese is noob.
Or you're good at Apex.
Like you play Apex really well.
You know it's like that.
My Chinese is noob.
Yeah.
It's true.
A lot of like curse words become like good words as well.
I can...
I can speak Chinese.
It's true.
Do you know there...
I think there's one more.
It's like...
Yeah.
So there's a...
They like to use English like sounding...
Like English words that sound like something else in Chinese as well.
Yeah like what?
So...
Can I use a...
Can I teach you a curse one?
A curse word?
Wait.
Oh okay.
But how curse?
It's...
It's like...
So it's this.
I'm gonna put it in chat.
It's not that bad.
What?
Not bad but...
I mean that's what they like to see.
I got taught this.
Can you try and think of it in your head?
And like guess what it is?
Wait but like what does it mean?
Wait what?
What does it mean?
It's not worse than...
Than...
So don't worry.
It's basically...
What does that mean?
What does it mean?
It's...
But it...
The word...
The sentence is like...
Funny...
Funny mud go pee.
But if you use...
If you use like a Chinese accent to say it's like...
Funny mud go pee.
Wait I don't...
I know that word.
I know.
I know because I've heard it in a movie.
I've heard it.
You heard it in a movie?
I've heard it in a movie.
Wait.
And then I'd be like...
Mom what's that word?
What?
And then I'd be like...
We know it's a bad word.
What?
You know like...
Like watching a movie and they say some very bad words.
I'd be like...
Dad what are they saying?
It's a very bad word.
Yeah.
It's interesting because like...
It's...
You know when...
Like they like to like trick...
I don't know why but like...
They like to play pranks basically.
It's not really a harmful one.
It's just like...
They like to say...
They put something in English and you like don't know what it is.
So you're like...
You read it out loud and people are like...
Hey don't say that.
It's like when people are like...
How do you say corn in Cantonese?
And then I'll be like...
I'm not gonna say corn in Cantonese.
Why?
No it's not.
But it's so stupid.
It's so stupid.
Okay.
So like...
Guys you didn't got me.
You didn't got me.
Okay it's an English joke but they use Cantonese to make you say it.
But like basically it's like...
In Cantonese to say corn is...
And then they'll be like...
You know?
Oh.
Oh I...
So they'll be like...
So they're like...
Oh you know Cantonese?
How do you say corn in Cantonese?
And they'll be like...
Oh my god suck my nuts.
Haha got him.
Oh I get it.
So it's like similar to that joke.
Yeah it is.
It is actually.
It's really funny though.
These kind of things are so interesting.
Holy shit.
Languages are so funny.
I know.
You know Dito right?
She taught...
Me... I think Nachan and I both...
Some like...
Oh some Thai curse words?
Oh no she taught me too.
Yeah.
I have like another friend that knows Thai.
And I was like hey I know Thai now.
And she was like...
How did you learn Thai?
I was like my friend taught me.
And then I said those curse words to her.
She was like...
You're in public by the way.
And she was like...
What the hell did you just say?
I'm not in public.
Yeah it was really...
It was really bad.
She had to hide her face.
She was hiding her face already.
Stop no.
I don't know you.
Knowing lots of languages...
Is really great.
It is.
Oh yeah.
It's really funny especially like when you go into public.
And then like somebody's talking in a different language.
That they think people don't understand.
And they're like gossiping.
And then you like eavesdrop.
Bro I had that happen.
Oh my god.
Bro I had like a negative experience with that.
I was like...
I embarrassed some fucking mom.
At like my school.
So like I don't remember where.
I think like I was just eating at a cafeteria.
And then like...
I think like...
The mom and the child...
The mom came over to give a lunch to one of the kids.
And then like they didn't realize I can speak Cantonese.
So then she like...
Was gossiping about like...
Oh I think she was like gossiping about my food or something.
Cause like...
I don't know.
Maybe I had like...
My food looked bad or something.
And then she was gossiping about it in Cantonese.
And then I turned around.
And then she was like...
I know what you're talking about.
And then she got...
She like instantly left.
Like she was so embarrassed.
And then like left.
And I was just like...
I was like...
She was like...
I know what you're talking about.
That must be so embarrassing though.
I would die of embarrassment honestly.
If that was me too.
I was like...
Bro what the fuck.
Yeah.
It's really funny.
It's actually really useful.
It's like you just assume like you don't know.
And like you're like I know.
Yeah they just don't know.
And then they're like saying...
Like gossiping in front of you too.
And then you're just like bro what the fuck.
I'm just eating.
It's like if you're gonna gossip in a different language.
Make sure they don't understand.
Or you get roasted hard.
Like maybe don't gossip in front of people.
Like don't...
You'll never know if they actually know your language.
I feel like aunties...
Like moms and grandmas...
Oh yeah.
They love the costumes.
Especially if they think the person doesn't know the language.
They'll just be like...
Oh you know how like...
My mom does this sometimes.
You know like...
If somebody in front of...
If there's someone that did something and they didn't like it.
And they'll just straight up be like...
Oh my god this person.
Right in front of them in a different language.
And then they'll just be like...
Oh hey...
They must be saying something nice about me.
Yeah.
It's so...
It's really awkward when they're like speaking...
For example like we're speaking English one moment.
And suddenly they switch to like...
They switch language to like...
Cantonese or Chinese or something.
You're like okay they're definitely saying something bad.
Like...
Oh my gosh.
I think I remember like...
Like I remember like sometimes like...
Cause like in Cantonese sometimes like...
Cantonese it sounds like we're talking like super harshly.
But like...
It's just like a normal...
Like we're just having a normal conversation.
And I remember like I was like...
I think I was like talking to my parents about something.
Like something like oh what do I want to eat or something.
And then like my friend was like...
Are you guys arguing?
Like why does this sound like...
Are you guys okay?
And I was like yeah I was just ordering food.
And then like my friend was like...
Are you guys arguing?
And I was like yeah I was just ordering food.
And then like my friend was like yeah I was just ordering food.
Yeah I do feel like...
Cantonese and Chinese does sound like...
I think if you don't know the language...
It sounds a little bit like aggressive.
But actually it's just how you say the words.
Yeah it's just like the intonation.
Yeah.
It just sounds aggressive to people who don't understand.
It's just...
Is there any other...
I think other languages as well.
Like you just don't understand what they're saying.
But it just sounds aggressive.
But actually they're talking about like...
Totally normal things.
Yeah it's actually so funny when people who don't understand...
Are they arguing?
I'm like no.
I'm just having a conversation.
Oh my god.
Have you guys watched any like...
Chinese movies?
Like animation... like pop culture Chinese movies?
Like famous ones.
Cause I was like thinking...
Do you know about Matau?
Or Matol?
But I think that's like...
Matau is like more Hong Kong though.
It's like really popular in Hong Kong.
What's that?
You know Matau?
It's like a story about pig.
Um...
And...
I know cause like...
I sort of like grew up with Matau.
And it's like... um...
Um...
It's like talking about like...
It's talking about like...
A pig.
But it's like a pig growing up.
When like growing up in Hong Kong.
And it's like...
It's like super memorable because it has...
Uh...
Because it has like a very memorable song.
And also like there was a scene about ordering food and stuff.
But like I think it might be too...
It's just like...
I don't think you would know.
It's old?
It's not old!
It's not everything I say is old!
Okay.
Is it too...
Probably because I don't know Cantonese.
Yeah.
I know it's like...
It's also...
It's very popular in Hong Kong.
But I know that...
It's also popular outside of Hong Kong.
But I don't know if you've watched it before.
It's not old!
It's pretty old to be honest.
No it's not!
Stop saying it's old!
Is it?
The last movie was in 2016 guys!
Whoa!
Eight years ago!
Okay the first movie was in 2001.
But like we don't...
Wait!
That's like...
Oh god!
It's not!
Nooooo!
I have not...
I have not seen that.
You never...
Honestly it's a good movie actually.
I think it's...
I think it was a really good childhood movie.
I didn't watch it in theaters!
I watched it on the DVD!
When my parents bought me a DVD!
Okay guys!
It's not that old!
When I watched it!
VIP seats again!
I didn't even get to watch it in the theaters!
I watched it in theaters!
As a DVD!
Because I was not old enough to watch it in the theaters!
DVD Boomer!
Who watches DVDs anymore?
DVD!
Yeah I haven't seen a DVD in years!
That's so true!
My PC doesn't even have a CD or DVD slot anymore.
Why did they stop that?
They stopped that in so long!
I don't know.
I also don't know.
I think...
I still had like...
Anime DVDs.
I was like into anime when I was young too.
But like...
I didn't know what anime is what.
And you know there's a lot of those like...
Like sus ones right?
Yeah.
Like...
You know...
One guy, 100 girls kind of anime.
No!
That's pretty sus.
I don't know those kinds because I'm...
Wait really?
I am here.
It's not like...
It's not like R18.
But you know it was like...
Kind of like...
The body would come...
And like...
And like I was like...
I remember there was like DVD and I was like really young at the time.
And then like I was...
I would go with my mom to like look at the DVD.
And like we bought...
Like we bought one.
And it was...
I think I can say the name.
It was like a Rosario Vampire.
Do you know that?
No I don't think so because I think I'm too...
Rosario Vampire.
Maybe I know the picture.
It was Rosario Vampire.
And I did...
It looked like very cute at first.
Because I was like oh it's a pink hair girl.
It looks so nice.
Oh it looks cute.
Yeah.
Okay so I got tricked by the cover of it.
Like there's nothing weird about the cover by the way.
So I bought it.
And like took it home.
And like I was watching it with my mom by the way.
And like...
We were both sitting there.
And like the first...
I think the first episode or something.
The guy like fell into the girl's like chest.
And like...
And my mom was like...
Oh god no.
Oh no.
It was like crazy.
And like...
My mom immediately like stopped the like DVD.
And she was like okay.
When you're older you can watch this.
And I was like...
Why?
Why can't I watch it?
I just bought it.
And she was like this is not for kids.
Yeah.
And I was like...
I got stopped.
Oh no.
You stay here for a little longer.
Yeah.
But then I secretly went with my like grandfather.
To buy like another DVD.
Oh my god they watched it.
But I bought a different one this time.
I bought Chobits.
Wait is it Chobits also...
I know Chobits but I never watched it.
But is it also similar?
It just looks cute.
It does look cute.
Like honestly...
Chobits looks so like...
The girl like Chi.
Her name is Chi.
And she looks very cute on the cover.
And I was like oh this is so cute.
And I bought it as well.
And like I started watching it.
I was like no.
Oh no.
What does this mean?
What is she doing?
And then I knew like oh god they're showing their body again.
I can't let my mom find out.
I was like what does this mean?
And then I looked it up.
Oh my gosh the beach episode.
Oh no.
Everyday was the beach episode.
Everyday.
Yeah.
That reminded me.
Oh my gosh I don't know how to pronounce it.
Let me google this.
Real fast.
There's like the famous dance.
The Caramella...
Is it the Caramella dance?
Oh can you know the Caramella dance?
Oh yeah.
You know that dance right?
Yeah I do.
You know the origin of that dance right?
I found that out recently.
Okay for those who don't know.
The dance.
The origin of that dance.
Is.
It's not.
It's 18 plus.
Let's just say.
Really?
Wait really?
I didn't know that.
Wait you didn't know that?
What did you know?
I just knew about the cute.
The one that they dance all the time.
The old video.
Where the girls are just dancing.
The origin of it was that the dance came from a porn game.
Oh!
Wait really?
Yes I found out.
I found out.
Like.
A couple of months ago.
Cause people were like talking.
Do you guys remember this dance?
Oh sorry.
A porn visual novel.
Which.
Thank you for correcting me.
What?
Yeah.
It was like the opening scene.
For like the opening intro.
For that game.
It's so weird that people took that dance.
When the origin of the game.
When the game came out.
It was like innocent.
Like in the video I saw.
They were just doing like a cute little dance.
I'm like.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm about to google.
Carmel dance in origin.
You know?
Yeah it is.
Oh wait.
I'm kind of like.
My experience with it is kind of like.
Gone right now.
I thought it was really cute.
I just thought it was cute.
Now I'm thinking damn.
Oh my god.
This is the.
I'm not going to.
I don't know if my mod should like.
Like.
Give the name of the.
This is the visual novel.
If I google that.
Someone.
Someone in my chat was like.
What is it called?
Erogue.
Yeah ergo.
Oh my god.
My google chrome is telling me.
Safe search.
Your chrome is like.
It's trying to save you.
They're like.
I don't know.
Safe search is on.
Oh no.
Wait.
But it looks so cute.
Is this an ergo?
Really?
It looks so cute though.
For my research purposes.
Yes it is not.
It's not just that.
I was like.
There's no way.
Just like you I was innocent and pure.
And I was like there's no way.
And then I looked further.
And I was like oh.
Wait.
No.
But it looks so innocent.
Like the first few images.
Totally.
It looks normal.
It just looks like.
It just looks like an old anime.
Wait.
Is the same character designer.
As the Monogatari series.
Wait.
Really?
Oh my god.
Wait I think it.
Oh my god it is.
It's the same character designer.
Oh my god.
Did you watch Monogatari?
No I didn't.
But I know about the show.
And it was super famous.
Do you know there's like a tongue twister in that one?
I really like that.
Oh is it the Nyan.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Let me try.
Can you say it?
I know I cannot say it.
I used to say it.
Like Baketono.
Tongue twister.
Yeah it's right there.
Umm.
Yeah it's this one.
Say it.
Naname nanaji o nanadono.
Narabide nakunaku.
Ina nakuna nanan.
Nanadai nanaku.
Narabete naganagame.
I'm pretty sure I butchered that.
Cute.
Okay.
How do you...
I'll try.
I remember I used to be able to do it.
I don't know if I can do it now.
Like.
Naname nanaji o nanadono.
Narabide nakunaku.
Ina nakunanana.
Nanakunarabe nanaganame.
Oh my god.
Oh and then you replace all the...
Oh yeah you replace all the na's with nya.
Nyananame nyananame.
Nyaname nyananame.
I cannot do it.
You should be able to do it because you're a cat.
A cat girl.
I mouth.
We've been like chatting.
Like an English thing.
For me I'm like going like when I'm talking in English like my brain is like fully in English.
And when I'm talking in Chinese I'm talking fully in Chinese.
When I'm talking in Japanese I'm fully in Japanese.
Actually I can multitask you know.
I'm really bad at multitasking.
Oh me too.
I'm really bad.
Like I tried before to like multitask.
And I just failed.
I was like...
No.
What did you try to do?
No like anything.
Like whenever I tried multitask.
I just like...
I can't.
I just can't.
Yeah then it's just too much.
Nya.
I have a bad...
Do you know I used to have a really bad habit?
Like I would actually do that by the way.
Like unironically.
Just be like Nya.
Just have that cat accent.
Like unironically.
Not even Vtuber by the way.
Like I go live.
Just like out in public and you're like you wanna do this?
Nya.
Yeah it was...
Like that.
It's really bad.
It's really bad though.
You did the thing.
I like trained myself to like stop it basically.
Because it was really embarrassing.
Like a long time.
Did she just Nya?
Yeah.
And yeah.
It was really really bad.
Like before I went to Bilibili as well.
But yeah it was really really bad.
I know your chat loves it though.
Your chat will be like do it again.
You know.
Like she did the thing.
Yeah.
But I did my best to like stop myself.
I would end my sentence with like Nya as well sometimes.
Oh.
Like not even thinking by the way.
It was really bad.
Like I don't know why.
What happened to me.
Yeah you just couldn't help yourself.
Yeah.
Nya.
Oh no you're looping.
It happens when I'm like not thinking by the way.
That's the problem.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
She's looping.
Let's change the chat.
Let's change.
Let me not say yes.
I just wanna get.
You know we've been talking for more than three hours.
How much Chinese have we talked?
That's crazy.
That's the important part here.
Okay.
We don't look at percentages.
We don't look at the percentages and the stats.
Do you want to fight?
My title said I try.
And I did try.
I tried so hard.
You know you're supposed to You're supposed to train me to talk in Chinese more.
Nya.
Use a little Chinese.
We're starting to use Chinese now.
Okay.
We're speaking Chinese.
But we've been talking for a long time.
We've been talking for too long.
Too long?
What's long?
Jiu is like long.
Oh.
We've been talking for a long time.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
I'm learning.
I'm sorry.
I'm not learning in Chinese.
Chinese.
I'm broken.
I also say broken.
No.
Not me.
Wait.
Broken means like shit.
No.
It's like How do you say it?
It's like a less like a less like like a curse way of No.
I got it.
No.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'm in Chinese.
I have an accent.
Okay.
Yeah.
I say that when something goes like if something goes wrong, you can say like It's bad.
It's bad.
It's broken.
It basically means it's like broken.
But it's not really.
It doesn't mean broken.
It's just like Damn.
What's learning again in Chinese?
學習 學習 學習 學 is like learn.
學習 is like Yeah.
我學習啦 Am I pronouncing it correctly?
學習中文 我學習中文啦 Yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
I can say it.
You know 夠了 right?
It's good enough.
Oh, 夠了.
Yeah.
It's like in Cantonese.
夠了 Yeah.
Wait.
You can understand Cantonese, right?
A little bit.
Can we have a conversation where you speak Chinese and I speak Cantonese?
Really?
Let's just try.
Okay.
Let's try.
So what did we say today?
What did we say?
What did you eat today?
I forgot.
I forgot what I ate.
I don't know what I ate.
You didn't eat anything?
Today Today?
I remember what I ate today.
Today?
Today...
What did I eat?
Rice.
You ate rice?
Rice?
Oh, 1 o'clock?
Now?
Now...
4... 4... 4.30.
I was like number 1.
Wow.
That's not that bad.
You ate...
Did you eat...
Sorry, my brain is like trying to fucking remember.
I'm trying to listen to your Cantonese.
You're listening to me.
I really don't know.
I can't hear you.
You can hear me.
I can hear you.
I'm thinking how to say it.
It's hard.
It's really hard.
Are you saying what I'm saying?
I can hear what you're saying.
But I'm thinking.
I'm thinking about what you're saying.
My brain is...
And then...
We're thinking about English.
We're thinking about so many things together.
Oh my god.
I didn't hear you.
What?
Okay.
I'm...
I'm saying...
I'm listening to you.
I'm listening to myself.
I'm thinking about how to say it.
I'm thinking about English.
I'm thinking about...
Does he know what I'm saying?
Because I'm speaking really fast.
I'm thinking...
I think he doesn't know what I'm saying.
He's pretending to know what I'm saying.
I know.
He doesn't know what I'm saying.
I understand.
You said it.
We're saying the same thing.
It's the same.
You're saying it really fast.
And then I'm saying something.
Yes, yes.
I understand.
Do you know what I'm saying?
What?
One more time.
What did I just say?
I don't know.
I'm asking you what you're saying.
I'm saying...
Do you know what I'm saying?
I don't know.
I don't know how to say it.
I don't know how to say it in Cantonese.
I can't say anything.
Not a little bit.
I'm not that good at speaking.
Oh my God.
Help me.
You know what I'm saying?
Like...
It means help me.
Yeah, help me is like save me.
But I always say help me.
Help me.
Save me.
Is it hard?
We've said a lot.
I think we've said the most.
We've said the most.
That's right.
You want to praise me?
I really can't.
I can't hear you at all.
I can hear you a little bit.
I think I can hear you more than you can hear me.
I think I can hear you a little bit.
do you want to say a little bit of Chinese today?
I've said a lot.
I don't understand what you are saying.
I said it's funny.
Then what did you learn?
Tell me.
What did you learn today?
I learned...
A-S...
A-W-S-L I'm dead.
You still remember.
See?
Look, look, look.
I can do it.
A-A...A-W-S-L I'm dead.
Look, look, look.
I can do it.
I can say it.
I know.
You lost that one.
I can...I know.
Fencing.
You?
Yes.
No problem.
What is fencing?
I don't remember.
I asked this.
I asked the Discord.
Oh, wait.
Is it...
You don't remember.
I know.
Chicken...
You...
You.
It's fencing with you.
Dstein...
But everyone thinks you are good at fencing.
We have a shadow dirt table where my colleague is helping her and learning how to play surgically.
Can this...
really not work?
This can't work.
Can't use...
Why not?
Why can't I use it?
This is 1v1 me.
1v1 you.
D-Zhan.
Eh?
What is 1v1?
She said...
D-E-D-A-E-D-A D-E-D-A-E?
D-E-D-A-E?
D-E-D-A-E-D-A-E D-E-D-A-E-D-A-E-D-A D-E-D-A-E-D-A-E-D-A I make my own tongue twister.
D-E-D-A-E-D-A-E-D-A D-E-D-A-E-D-A-E-D-A But you don't know...
Japanese, right?
What?
You don't know Japanese, right?
Japanese.
You don't know Japanese, don't you?
No...
Wait, no!
Murasaki.
Armor.
Idiot.
Murasaki.
I understand.
I did it!
Murasaki armor.
Yeah!
That's all I need.
I know the...
What's about the important information?
Do you want to know what like...
He's one in Chinese.
Oh, wait, wait.
What is it?
Like, one dead.
One dead.
Yeah, he's one.
It's not really that dead, but like...
It's basically that dead.
I see, I see.
Oh my god, see guys?
Don't trust that, by the way.
If you ever hear that, it's never...
The same in English too.
There was somebody's name that was like...
He's one and it's...
Okay, I'll type it out.
It's actually so funny.
I saw someone's name.
It's like he's one and then...
Quote, I mean...
I hit him once.
And it's like...
It's like my favorite.
It's one of my favorite names.
Yeah, it's actually...
Actually it's the same in Chinese too.
It's like...
It's not that he's one in Chinese.
It's my own meaning.
Yeah, yeah.
It's not that he's one in Chinese.
I hit him once.
I remember like...
I said that once.
I was like...
Or it's like...
I'm the one that's like...
I'm the one that's like almost dead.
Oh my god, I remember like...
I said this once.
I was like, he's one!
And then like...
I think it was on stream before a long time.
My friend was like, what do you mean he's one?
And I was like, he was like...
40 HP.
And I was like, he's one bullet.
He's one headshot.
He was one!
It's one headshot!
It's so funny.
Very like...
Like the...
He's one in all languages.
Honestly the same, I think.
So it's like...
One creeper headshot.
He's one!
One creeper headshot!
Oh my god.
I had a great... I had fun...
Oh my god, we fucking talked for so long.
It's going to...
I do have another collab.
Yes!
You know that game?
I don't know if you know.
It's like...
On Steam now, I think...
Abiotic Factor.
Abiotic Factor?
Is it the one that's like...
Content creation but...
It's like...
Half-life a little bit.
Wait, oh wait.
Maybe I'm not talking about the same game.
It was another game that came out.
That was like the content...
Oh my gosh.
What was that content game we played?
Content warning you mean?
Yeah, yeah.
There was a game that was like...
You forgot?
My brain is not doing so well right now.
Abiotic Factor.
I never heard about that game.
What is that game?
Yeah, I'm about to play it tonight.
I had no idea as well.
Oh, it's a survival crafter.
Oh, it's a survival game.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know what it's about.
But apparently it's...
a little bit like lethal company.
Oh.
It's not really like content warning.
It's like a little bit lethal company but like...
half-life inspired or something like that.
Oh, wait.
That's so cool.
If it's half-life inspired.
I don't know.
I'm reading it's like a survival crafter.
So I feel like it's like a game that you're supposed to play longer than one time.
It's survival half-life.
Yeah, yeah.
Survival half-life.
It's interesting though.
Yeah, it sounds interesting.
Yeah, I'm gonna be collabing that later with Nachan too.
Nachan.
How many hours will you guys be playing in?
Not sure.
We'll be big again.
Usually for us, we're like...
You know, for me at least.
Me and my closer friends on Vimeo.
We're just like, okay we'll play it and we'll see what time we end.
Kind of thing.
But like when's your collab?
Oh, it's like...
It's like at 8 but I'm gonna go eat something.
Oh, you should go eat.
Yeah.
I had a great time...
Yapping with you, Hiro.
Yeah, we were so...
Yeah, we talked...
It did not feel like almost 4 hours to be fair.
I did not feel like I was talking for 4 hours.
Yeah.
Chatting.
Just chatting.
Yeah, just chatting.
It's nice to just chat though.
We didn't clickbait.
We had a very long conversation like 10 minutes ago.
Guys, there was no clickbait here.
It's true.
We did.
We did talk.
We tried so hard.
Our brain is like...
Our brain right now is overheating.
Wait, what?
What does it mean?
Please praise me.
Yeah.
You can try it cute.
Say it cutely.
You go first.
Please praise me.
I can do that too.
That's cute.
Yes, let's all say thank you to Hiro for being a great teacher and like bringing me up to date because I'm not old.
I'm not auntie.
I'm not an auntie.
I'm young.
No, thank you for chatting with me.
We should play something.
You know, I'm...
Wait, did you know?
Dito, Nacha and I were watching the ALGS together.
Oh yes, I saw you guys were watching.
We're gonna play Apex tomorrow.
Oh yeah, the new season.
The new season.
We should play sometime.
Yeah, we should.
We should play something again soon.
It was great talking to you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for joining.
For accepting the invite to just talk.
Of course.
Every time it's like having a conversation about like random things.
And like I hope you learned a lot about animals.
I learned Cantonese actually.
Cantonese too.
I hope you learned a lot about Cantonese language.
And also a lot about pandas.
I love pandas.
I learned about rats too.
Yeah, and rats too.
Thank you for your rats fact.
We should like...
We should visit a zoo one day just to look at pandas together.
Just look at them.
Just be like, we learned so much about you guys.
Sure.
I'm down.
You know?
Just go to visit a zoo somewhere just to see the pandas and be like, this is how we bonded.
God.
God, they're stupid.
And sun bears.
We should see a sun bear together.
Grab like a giant cutout of us and just put them next to the...
Sun bear.
You think the zoos will let us bring a cutout of us?
Like a life-size cutout and we just put it...
Like our 2D...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just put it there with the sun bear and the panda and I'll be like, oh my god pandas, you're so fucking stupid but you're so cute.
God, I wish.
It's a scared animal.
But yes, let's all say goodbye to Hiro and thank you for teaching.
Thank you.
No, thank you.
Bye bye.
Yeah, let's chat again sometime.
My brain is like mush right now.
I don't even know how to do an outro.
Hiro, do my outro for me.
Do your outro for you?
Yeah.
What do you want me to do?
I don't know.
How do you do your outros?
Use your outro for my stream.
Really?
Yeah.
You want me to do my outro?
My outro kinda...
Like, okay.
At first I'll thank for like thank you for the super chat.
Thanks for the gifts and thanks for the members and all that.
And then I'll give them a little kiss though.
Okay, yeah, do it.
Come on.
Really?
Yeah, and do it in Chinese.
How?
Okay.
Thank you for the gifts.
Thank you captain.
Captain is what they call it.
Like captain.
Yeah.
Thank you for coming to today's stream.
Thank you.
Please pay attention to Doki.
Wow, that's me.
Yeah.
It's me.
Wow.
You need to kiss.
You need to kiss too.
I need to?
Because I'm going to kiss.
Why?
You did it.
Why do I have to do it?
Because it's your stream.
Hahaha.
Who should do it right?
That's true.
Okay, guys.
I'll do a countdown everybody.
Alright, guys.
3, 2, 1.